food
hello everybody and welcome it is Monday
February 27th it is cold
out here in Los Angeles
but I'll tell you what
there's one man that's not affected he's
goes rain shine sleet snow sunny it's
shirtless Eddie
by the way guys this shot go show the
white again bro I do not like this shot
look at my legs it looks like a [__]
beast bro look how fat where you can't
do that to me what is this shot
justify this what what are you upset
about look at me look show me look at my
legs dude you're not supposed to see my
legs like that what the hell Dan do
something yeah it looks like I've been
photoshopped literally
60 seconds ago you looked at the shot
and you're like it looks great I love
this
hmm it's me I don't remember saying that
yeah it was just well two minutes ago
well I didn't realize show my legs again
I look like a damn like one of those
edits where my body looks all [__] up
it doesn't look that weird I think it's
just yeah and Eddie you've been checking
your zipper what's the concern over
there yeah because on the last time I
was uh on your podcast you told me that
uh Eddie uh has kind of like a zippered
down or so I'm one of the fans had said
that I was one of the fans from my Tick
Tock uh Eddie Levesque and so I want to
make sure it's always up every time
right so you're a shirt you are
shirtless but zipper up zipped up and
shirtless Eddie that's right yeah
Eddie's joining us today as kind of like
a okay guys seriously this is not an
appropriate shot
this is not professional
thank you
yeah so Eddie's joining us today kind of
in a co-host format he's kind of like
are you would you take cross with it's
kind of like a sidekick roll yeah yeah
you back me up you build me up basically
never cross me and always build me up
that's what I expect from you yeah
yeah the last guy that crossed me
you don't want to know what happened to
him
yep are you cold right now no I'm
perfectly warm and fine really you run
hot or cold cold generally like in your
house do you run the AC or the heater
around this time usually the heater yeah
yeah
it is cold outside yeah the last guy who
double crossed me lost all of his hairs
oh wow so I have that so you know watch
it I'm I kid of course I love a shirt
yeah so today
um
today's episode is sponsored by Teddy
fresh thank you to ELA Klein
pick it out
everybody loves it teddyfresh.com
that's right we got the last chance sale
you can get up to 80 off on all these
classic items
check that out
and if you want some of the newer and
groovier stuff like this freaking denim
jacket
can be yours only five remaining of
large
denim trucker jacket and all kinds
teddyfresh.com check it out thank you
thank you please
thank you
well we got a lot planned today
my mom is calling in today awesome yeah
yeah she's a she's going to explain
um dubrick
yes she's going to explain I don't know
if you've been following the Selena
Gomez versus uh Haley Bieber drama
sure have you have been
wow you know Haley Bieber is jealous of
Selena being in all of that TV show that
she's in and every 10 time you get an
acting job then all of a sudden
everything goes out the window this is
incredible you wait so what acting job
does Selena have well she's in that only
murders in the building with you know uh
Steve Martin and Martin Short oh yeah so
she's jealous of you know Selena's all
of a sudden TV popularity wow her TV
quotient and so now probably she's uh
that's why that that's really insightful
actually shirtless Eddie with the gut
with the T I love that well my mom is
going to call in because there's been
honestly we've all been trying to
understand this drama and it's very hard
because
apparently everybody loves Selena Gomez
right and of course right who wouldn't
and then you got Haley Bieber who did
something mean about her eyebrows but
then and then everyone unfollowed
Haley Bieber and then a lot of people
followed Selena and like I've tried to
understand what like what did she do and
I just cannot so my mom's gonna call him
to explain perfect yeah trying to think
but nothing happens it's a lot more than
just eyebrows
dude only murders Selena's new hit show
has a hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes
so I think jealous might be the key yeah
good for her
good for her where you stand We Stand
Selena in this building right guys
I'm waiting to see I know enough about
the situation to to take a side we stand
Selena yes that's the safe position well
who's supporting Haley Bieber it's like
she's a monster I've unfollowed on
Instagram I don't know what she did
she's a monster yeah
yeah I wonder if this is going to affect
her relationship with Justin Bieber
you know lots of stress
he's already living a stress enough life
this is the last thing he needs his
stress from his wife right totally
ridiculous
yeah I don't know what she did though
um we've got a reminder at the top of
the show here we got our green screen
deadline is this Friday guys get your
green screen edits in
thank you Eddie does that mean we're
picking the winners on Monday
or are we picking them on Friday I think
on Friday we'll have like a mega show
where we watch them all that means the
deadline is the day we should say okay
Thursday yeah so if you're working on
one if you're working on your magnum
opus
they say that right
yeah
I didn't what did you say magnum opus
yeah okay I got it this time
get it in by Thursday
kabish
post on Reddit post it on Reddit
apparently but here's a few examples
because people have been really going
all out on these
and um he's fighting here let's take a
look at some of the ones that have been
submitted recently
let's take a look very hard but you need
to have realistic expectations Ethan hey
[__] talk now
yo put your hands up
put your hands up I'm not gonna ask you
again
I'm just in the podcast I lost a couple
weights and I love it oh that was an
homage to you oh my gosh yeah
[Music]
thank you
this is beautiful
hey you come over here often nice to see
you out here in the club
just forget about everything tonight
tonight's just about the boys
[Music]
open up FBI
stop right there
this guy over here is cooked all
different flavors
anyway I want to give a shout out to my
wife Chelsea who [__] my cousin over
the weekend [__] now my whole life is
look at the size of that
that is enormous
I have never seen something that big
holy smokes
dude that's so awesome
good they used everything all out I love
this don't [__] with me I got a gun in
my glove box
[Music]
everything seems so real what could
possibly be causing you to construct
this artificial reality wake up wake up
wow
[Applause]
the competition is going to be fierce
um
Fierce fears Fierce there of course we
have a huge first prize 500 doll hairs
500 macaroonies you know number two 300.
three and four a hundred dollars each
how generous am I
you are generous thank you for saying
that
appreciate you saying that that is good
thank you
also I don't know if you know but I
donated one ten thousand and one dollars
to the Turkish
you know how there was an earthquake
there yes very sad I donated ten
thousand one dollars
you are so incredible thank you awesome
thank you so much
yeah together we raised 1.3 million
dollars there
you know together
way to go Ethan thanks man 1.3 million
dollars who else does that you did it I
mean yeah exactly that's what I'm trying
to say raise it thank you 1.3 million
dollars
also I want to say Howie Mandel
uh fan and friend of the show retweeted
one of the green screens
wow so we are reaching International
Acclaim here on the podcast this is
Howie Mandel the one and only
new golden buzzer he says
there it is
[Applause]
welcome to America's Got Talent
oh that's the spirit
okay I cannot wait to see what you're
gonna do right here
go ahead buddy
let's Feel The Beat just forget about
everything tonight tonight's just about
the boys
just forget about it all man just let it
go
I love those dance moves I'm gonna have
to use those in my video thank you I
could show you that yeah I think you
guys just forget about everything
the audience loves you crickets man
forget about everything or maybe they're
enthralled I would talk about the voice
thank you brother
yeah
look at that footwork you know what I
kind of Hit the gritty pretty hard
yeah get that really nice low get that
gritty nice and low yeah hit that griddy
boy
is anyone still watching
um
yeah I understand that
Simon it looks so realistic like you're
really there I am well yeah yeah no we
have the best editors in the world
beautiful Howie's a friend of the show
of course
um and uh well thank you Howie for the
acknowledgment nothing yeah I appreciate
that how was your weekend by the way
Eddie oh it was really really good you
know I went to see a musical and I did a
bunch of videos I had a viral video that
uh happened really 2.2 million really
confused yeah wait let me pull it up is
that a new one oh yeah it was a new one
and you got a lot of followers too and
Views as well well yeah thank you for
one of yours got two million views as
well thank you for acknowledging that
I'm not quite sure uh which one you're a
little further down further down there's
the one that uh further down let's see
you posted all these one million see
there it is right there 2.1 million
views uh right there that one when would
you post this yeah that one was posted
just about four days ago you post you
made all this content it says two days
you've been crushing it Eddie you're
like a prolific Creator I ramped it up
for you Ethan to make sure that when I
come on this show and sit on this couch
that any big so I was asked another
question I was going to ask you who is
sat on this couch before because I heard
it's a really uh an honor to be on this
yeah
um
and to be next to you at this desk is a
real honor thank you so much the honor
is mine to have a tick tock star here
shirtless Eddie let's take a look
so what so tell me
set around here because they're already
like laughing yeah how did you approach
them I think maybe they see that I was
doing another video with other people or
a little further away and they kind of
chuckled at that as they were watching
it so then they kind of got into it when
I went to them you know you saw they
were watching and you said hey these
these people are they understand their
eye they were seeing that I was doing
another uh Tick Tock right there and
they kind of were laughing at it so then
they wanted to maybe partake in it okay
and so what do you ask them when you
approach them yeah I just say hey dude
you know I'm going to be on the H3
podcast would you like to do a video
let's see if it goes viral so that when
I get on Ethan's H3 podcast you said
that to them we'll have another big
winner well there you go the and they
say sure that's what it was so um here
it is 2.1 million
maybe maybe overstepping a little bit
yeah yeah yeah they need to respect your
Artistic integrity yes yeah yeah yeah
but regardless it was a hit maybe they
were right yeah because this one went
viral yeah it did and I wasn't expecting
hey what are you doing
today too to do some more Walmart videos
to see if they would go viral as well
right yeah we'll see the next job stop
is uh maybe Sprouts over in Sprouts
fertile yeah fertile lands yeah have you
ever been asked to leave a store well
you told us about the Costco one yeah
that was the only time yeah and then I
noticed one time when I went to the
Walmart all of a sudden they were
following me around so I could see
through the corner of my eye that this
Purity was about ready to catch me or
tell me to leave the store so I I over
uh you know went faster than they could
catch me yeah I was able to exit the
store myself yeah
so here is the viral hit by shirtless
Eddie love how do you say your last name
lovese that sounds Italian but I'm you
know Jewish oh you're Jewish just all
right look I am brother and uh
[Music]
they don't seem that eager I gotta be
honest they were like leaving they
wanted to go over there this guy was
like why are you making me do this
almost
without your shirt off
or maybe he was active
oh yeah I love being cheerless at the
Walmart hey I love being sure listen I'm
starting to have more confidence in
standing straighter now you know kind of
getting more uh wow before I think I was
a little more Hunchback and a little
more like worried that you know I was
like crossing boundaries but now it's
just getting better at a trial yeah hey
this is interesting the top comment both
say this is like internet
interdimensional cable which is a bit
from Rick and Morty written by Justin
Roiland who is sat in this chair
how was your guys's weekend uh beautiful
thank you for seeing that you guys have
a good weekend yeah everyone's good good
good
oh you're muted who's we uh the crew we
hung out a lot we went uh the girls had
a girls night at our apartment on Friday
and then on Saturday we all went to go
watch cocaine bear which was uh what is
cocaine bear I've been hearing about
this very dumb movie so good that was
Ray Liotta's last movie and then he died
very important later I wonder if he you
know overdid it or got into relapse
because you think he cocained yeah was
there cocaine consumption in the film
um there was I I can't we're just being
around that it was real pain yeah maybe
what were you I'd be unfortunate if that
is the reason that he died because it is
quite not worth it yeah it's not worth
it yeah the great Ray Liotta died to go
from Goodfellas to uh cocaine bear not
worth it huh yeah no
was she I bet he wishes he could do a
take back on that right yeah yeah taking
him back one of the girls he's dead
he said well if he were alive right he
would win oh I see you right yeah yeah
because you were saying you bet he
wished that he could take it back well
from you know he's deceased now no I
understand that thank you Dan ladies
what are we doing on Friday night
everyone's getting together
yeah we had a lot of fun we ordered
dinner
we we had a scary incident actually with
the Postmates oh so true but other than
that was fine it was great yeah yeah
yeah what are you eating there Lena is
that a flaming hot Cheeto no it's just
some gummy worms okay okay I thought
that was interesting the flaming hot
Cheeto okay good what was the incident
on Postmates you guys want to elaborate
um Let me please girls don't docs us
when you tell this story please I'm very
afraid I just had this crazy ass
postmate
like she called when she arrived and she
was like where are you hurry up I'm here
Oreo Pronto Pronto like nine times oh
yeah Pronto pronto did she have a bad
rating or was she highly rated what was
the issue
um I don't remember what her rating was
it yeah I don't know I think maybe she
was just waiting a little bit too long
and it was raining which I understand
but she was like screaming on the phone
and I was scared actually I was like we
should tell her just drop the bat just
leave them and we'll grab them fine
because I didn't want to like go face to
face with her right that makes sense
yeah so did any so did anyone meet her
face to face what ended up happening
Lena and I went out and we saw her at
the door just holding the food like this
so we opened the door very quickly we're
just like thank you so much a great
night and she she began to yell a bit
really she was like it's been the it
we're so sorry thank you so much and
then we just cracked my
real a bad person she was just waiting a
long time I think yeah there it is so we
had a bit of a street we had a bit of a
spooky Postmates story there over the
weekend and then AB terrified us when he
came in the door like five minutes later
I walked in and they all screamed
yeah you guys are funny man
your doorbell was a mute was a movie I
do have a pretty epic doorbell I
literally
it's like a bunch of trumpets I can't
even it's like walking to Disneyland we
didn't it was there when we got the
place uh it was terrifying yeah there it
is guys lots of excitement over the
weekend it is really pouring here man
it's crazy uh our office is leaking like
a damn faucet how many buckets we got
out uh one
two three four five we're trying like
six I'm trying to get the roof fixed
luckily
there's no leaks over the electronics
which is pretty of God you might even
say yeah and knock on wood yeah
we're good there I actually I almost
sealed the deal with this one roof
repair guy
now now me and my wife were Israeli yeah
or while I'm dual citizen so is my wife
but but I was born here but so we happen
to know that
Israelis here that do contract work
are like 90 scammers they're just
in my experience and this is well known
is that they just cannot be trusted okay
and I'm sure there's some larger there's
some larger statement to be made on that
oh my God stop
they just can't they come out because
here here's the deal in Israel it's a
dog eat dog world
and everybody's scamming each other
everyone's trying to get the head up on
each other yeah but in America that's
not the culture and people here are more
trusting and for this the Israelis who
have bad intent and see they almost come
out here like it's a feeding ground for
them and so I I saw his name
on the uh the estimate and his name was
Israel Cohen
they the Israelis now now hold on quite
literally could not have a more Israeli
name
well it yeah because that's the thing
they love finding Jews to do business
with because you know Americans usually
go oh we trust each other right I would
trust another Jew in Israel it's not
like that they're all Jews they don't
give a [__] right
and so I see his name and I says does he
have an accent Israel Coleman is he
American he goes and then our office
manager says
he he did have an accent but I don't
know from where it was I said he's
Israeli so I said do you need to look
into this guy
so he does a background check finds out
that his license
was less than a year old if you go to
the better Better Business Bureau and
Yelp and all this stuff he's got like
dozens of five star reviews not a single
bad review and if you've been on the
Better Business Bureau
it doesn't matter how legit your
business is you're going to have people
complaining there right and so my my
scam alarm started buzzing
and I said this guy's about to uh
this guy's about to run away with it and
so you know my my Israeli tingles were
going off and uh we evaded that but
unfortunately our roof is still leaking
but every word you get for that yeah but
but I feel I can say that as an Israeli
dual citizen American Jew I can say the
Israelis are scammers
now if it was a different location if I
said for example all Italians are
scammers that would be out of pocket and
I don't believe that for the record
but I have credentials that one might
say
you know so if you so if Israelis give
you a bid
just you know give it a second look
thank you that's my uh PSA for the day
now what now what
you know even a real you know you know
and let them know absolutely I see
someone in the brief after you got it
you know this is just my knowledge my
wealth of knowledge with the I share it
with the world
I don't hold back someone said Mexican
contractors for the win actually I agree
dude oh 100 Rush at every time actually
and I saw somebody point out Israel is
Mexican name too no no he wasn't Mexican
no and the Cohen is the tales the Cohen
just I was like nah I'm not working with
no Cullen
without looking into it first please no
actually well Cohen is an American is
more American last name in my opinion so
I asked him
look into it before I we cut him loose
and you know sure enough
I I flipped that Lanka right on its head
in Yiddish we call that a ghanaf like a
thief a gunf a dirty God oh [__] I
shouldn't say the dirty that comes off
from Donna
it is for thief yeah yeah but I am an
Israeli dual citizen uh and my wife is
Israeli that's why I know
if LED is queuing me up for his next
thumbnail
somebody but Friendly Fire enabled and
then the star of a friendly fire behave
listen
my intuition was right no you were right
no I know it's just I know that I know
this
I've known the Israeli people man what
can I say
and I've heard about it so many times
like they either they come they're
gardeners they're contractors their
roofers you know and they'll they'll
burn you man
every damn time
you know what I'm saying I know what
you're saying yes sir
and so which which ethnic group do you
hold Prejudice I'm just kidding don't
answer that
just testing the waters you thought
about it yeah
you thought about it
no kill switch yet baby would you kill
switch that I mean this was not that bad
right
no no but but I can see your I would
have advised you to not tell the story
on air though yeah this is a live show
and I have a reputation of uh putting my
foot in my mouth
all the time and we're getting uh kill a
quick kill switch so that we can I saw
like a live broadcast yeah that looks
really good thank you so much
yeah actually huge news
um
coming in from Detroit
really slow news days over at uh the
Detroit Free Press the number one
publication in Michigan is that right
that is right really look at this they
wrote it did a a write-up on our very
own a b
yeah all my uh I love them I want one oh
wow I got you Eddie wow oh thank you
yes so um a b a local hero out in
Detroit did they mention that you saved
a family from a burning wreckage on the
freeway they did not know that no they
couldn't they couldn't they're crowning
achievement dude they couldn't in fact
check that unfortunately uh Detroit
content creator was set for medical
career when one YouTube video changed
everything
I like that it honors me a little bit as
well oh yeah if you if you Google wait
what was the one YouTube video the video
I made defining Ethan yeah it makes me
look like So Vain and pathetic
they're like
this guy defended me he gets a job
that's not what happened yeah I heard
the record I got to know him a lot yeah
before I we hired him and he was a good
he was a good uh apple good seed what's
the burrito he's a good burrito yeah
really goodbye yeah seven layer on
Google it says AB from YouTube's H3
podcast got big break from Ethan Klein
that's how it's titled if you just like
Google it that's awesome oh look at you
guys they really honored you man I've
never I don't even think I've had a
write-up this in depth I still got some
some street cred in Detroit damn
check this out
working for the H3 podcast this is the
part that interests me
in 2008 oh [__]
in 2018
ayad posted a commentary video YouTube
defending the host of the H3 podcast
from criticism Ethan being such a um
Ethan being such a vain loser actually
just hired him because everybody else on
the internet hated him well they wrote
that
that's harsh kind of wild
when I released it I hardly got any
views it was flooded with hate comments
I just assumed it was just another
failure and a long line of failures oh
come on AB
you're being a little bit harsh on
yourself don't you think
[__] no I was a loser for years please
what do you mean I was my whole family
thought I was a loser not Athena
not me but I can confirm he was failing
it was failure after failure
dude you still bagged yourself a beauty
queen so I did I did true you're a loser
uh I didn't think about it for years I
didn't even watch it back since then had
it really been out that long oh yeah
that's so weird I wonder why I came back
to it and watched it I don't remember I
I remember I don't know if it's worth
getting into but keemstar was sharing
the other video that I responded to um
and then mine came back up Klein
students started watching ayad's live
streams okay that's nice that they put a
little context into this found this
commentary video subscribe to his
channel follow him on Twitter and later
offer him a job after a consistent
communication this is this is something
journalism this is good journalism wait
they really did their research and they
couldn't confirm the burning car story I
don't want to loop back to that no I
tried sending that little video after
the the burning but that didn't work
be honest did you supply this
information to them
uh yeah some of it okay a lot of the
stuff before the crater Clash was sort
of like just from my videos primarily I
have a video about being hired in 2020
um and a lot of people get information
from that I just discovered this is a
nice photo look a b with with admiring
eyes for his lovely wife Lena
this is me in the background yeah
Creator Clash two you're oh yeah dude
they use this photo they really honoring
you brother
yeah you know look at that can you
believe that AB beat the [__] out of
this guy and he was way bigger than him
he punched him yeah he punched him right
that's that's the least of what you did
to him
um missing home wow
although living in La working for pagas
he was a long-term fan of his dream come
true
they still visit their family in
Michigan
they make sure to frequent small Middle
Eastern bakeries they miss such as
King's Bakery
Golden Bakery and yes means in Dearborn
three you have three bakeries you hit up
I didn't know it was going to be quoted
and all that but yeah
man you must love scones or some [__] or
no it's a lot better than scones
yeah yeah is that out and all that
that's beautiful well congratulations
guys Detroit honors you all thank you
the great city of Detroit thank you now
let's see if if the city of Dearborn
repost it that's going to be the real
the city of Dearborn Instagram is a big
deal in our hometown let's see if they
repost it let's see what's the other
like what are the front lines stories if
they're running that kind of stuff like
uh you know cat gets stuck in tree Local
Hero rescues him
no we kid AB we love him yeah he's a
good kid
thank you that's kind of fun though were
you excited like how long was this in
the works for you uh yeah no I was it's
been a while since I did this interview
I was telling you about it a while back
but uh they uh took a while to release
it my dad actually sent it to me this
morning oh that's so nice yeah they're
probably doing fact checking which is
why they didn't include the burning
record right
yeah very interesting to me you know
Howie Mandel I mentioned is a friend of
the show
he had a podcast
with Anthony wait he was on Anthony's
show
and then Anthony came on his show okay
okay yeah so here's Howie on this guy
Anthony Padilla he's a YouTuber uh less
popular than me but uh people like him
and uh that's actually not true
uh but anyway here's Howie here's Howie
talking about us come out oh it comes
out and when it comes out it doesn't go
back in no it does really so Ethan Klein
I did his uh podcast yeah and he had a
guy on he turned around and he
blew it out and then sucked it back he
showed you in person on uh would it be
called FaceTime yeah you're what you're
he's shocked because he doesn't know how
a real show operates Anthony you sit
there and you ask questions oh wow so
interesting I show prolapses live to
guess and that's where I'm different
than him
and that's kind of you know
the bleeding edge of uh how do you feel
about anal prolapses Eddie
well they're pretty bad they're bad yeah
yeah some people like them we did a
whole kind of Adventure some people like
sexually the the the prolapse yeah yeah
so I guess Different Strokes for
different folks right to each his own
exactly Well yeah if he does that it
would be live and let prolapse yeah
I don't think they showed that on the
air they showed my response and that's
why even now on my merch I sell the
there's a shirt that says is this covid
related sure that's what it means you
lost the sponsors but you sure gained
you gained something more there's only a
few left if you're gonna click on Howie
man okay Anthony I don't want to
criticize your interviewing skills but
did you really sure that's not what this
is related man like that's literally you
didn't even Howie's big moment he said
that's what he's famous for that's it
that's literally who is Howie Mandel
he's the prolabs guy right on my merch I
sell the there's a shirt that says is
this covid related oh [__] that's what
it means
disgraceful that's what it means like he
was looking through his merch earlier
disgraceful
actually uh Anthony Padilla we love you
uh but that was nice I love Howie he
gives me so much respect he's he's
retweeting us he's talking about us he's
how he's just such a great guy he really
is a friends of the show through and
through
um
but what's interesting is Anthony
Padilla
went on Howie's podcast which I've also
been on actually got I was the most
viewed for a while Jeff Dunham passed me
recently which is not a good situation
awful
I I still don't get it
Jeff Dunham
I don't like I don't think he's very
funny do you no no yeah
thank you for saying that the pop what's
with the puppet puppets you know who
cares better than that thank you Eddie
you understood good guy over here this
Eddie could get used to sitting next to
him
but here's Anthony Padilla from six days
ago
on how he's now um
um can you just
can can you just read me the views it's
kind of small I can't or I can't make it
out my eyes are what they used to be and
it's really small on the screen Dan can
you read it that looks like 7.5
000. after six days all right okay the
great and okay right oh see yeah I see
that that's not a lot that's a small
quantity of views
Anthony Padilla bro maybe if you showed
your guess prolapses more people would
be interested in your content
just saying
um that is actually that it I don't know
if this is Howie's fault or Anthony's
fault who we blaming for it's Anthony
yeah it's Anthony yeah no clearly yeah
look at the look at the episodes uh
proceeding
yeah because if you look at for example
the views on the other ones if you go to
most popular I mean here I am with
almost half a million views wow which is
staggering that is huge
but actually Jeff Dunham what the [__]
bro he's got
yeah like 50k on me yeah over 50K
um
I think I don't make any accusations but
like viewbotting maybe it's possible you
think he's he is yeah he's vein like
that he would do that do you think Jeff
Dunham with viewbot yeah probably yeah
he's the type to do that
that's actually incredible though do you
want some merch uh hell yeah watch this
watch this watch this no
oh that was funny I like that how he's
good man like that he's trying go ahead
welcome to Howie Mandel does stuff I'm
Howie Mandel did it must be rich to like
justify like this crazy level of
production for 7 000 views like this is
super produced you know he's got like a
crew of like five or ten people every
time
it's awesome
that's awesome but we love them both
don't we folks maybe they get uh more
views on another platform
maybe he's on kick or uh Pluto TV
Pluto is that a Roku
yeah and I don't want to say I made
Howie Mandel but uh this is when I
appeared on his podcast
wow so we have a um ow
we have a symbiotic relation symbiotic
relationship like that if only you could
get people to subscribe to this channel
I know that's true we lose Subs here
every day no yeah we are bleeding
subscribers it's true exactly yeah but
you being here is gonna I'm gonna raise
the roof thank you brother this is I
think this is when Anthony was on
actually if you see this dot here
I don't know why I'm [__] on Anthony
I just like to flex on Howie because
he's my best pal
but I don't know what Anthony did to
deserve that uh that mistreatment he's a
good guy he's catching Strays he's
catching Strays actually I do applaud
Anthony because he reinvented himself in
a way that frankly I didn't think was
possible Anthony padillo is part of
Smosh
it was the biggest YouTube channel for a
while and he left to pursue his own
thing and he actually has done quite
well for himself I'm impressed with how
well his uh solo interviewing Show Goes
yes
fortunately as what good as his show
does clearly his fans don't follow him
to other shows because I guess they're
just not engaged enough like our fans
are I'm such a [__] today it's a petty
[__] today Ethan shut the [__] up dude
you know
well my mom is standing back and
standing by yeah she said uh like the
proud boys this is exciting she said
she's watching actually so hi Mom
let's see what else we got uh leading up
to my mom's great call
um
oh God the Jersey Outlaw updates dude so
this is
this is Jimmy Lee posted the student's
Instagram the angry old man he titled it
this is crazy
tell me what you guys think about this
uh here let me play it
oops need some volume here you didn't
tell me that last time you last time you
said everything
else is soup listen I want to sit here
alone you didn't tell me that
you last time
and that's a that's he uploaded that
very funny interaction of uh aggravating
and old man very funny content by Jimmy
Lee
actually did you guys find the full clip
because I felt like it was more there
was yeah there was just a slightly
longer version posted to was it on Tick
Tock do we have that one
Jimmy thinks that when he like genuinely
angers people that that's good content
I texted him asking about where the full
clip was too and he proceeded to
do the same five jokes we've heard a lot
oh he hit you with his regular routine
yeah he told me to go on a vacation
everyone
spectacle yeah
oh oh you guys got it yeah we got it so
here's Jimmy Lee working the streets
doing his thing
it's a soup
we had a viral moment what
what
it's happening this has curb energy
Bernie Sanders crazy Jimmy Lee has found
the audience on tick tock
well at least with that video
they don't understand the forces that
they're dealing with
these people have no idea holy [__] that
last time you least time you sat with
doors you told me last time to have
lunch with you now you change your mind
that wasn't nice
so so what's interesting is
it looks like Jimmy actually isn't
joking no he looks mad like they had
they had a genuine argument it looks
like
like I genuinely feel that Jimmy
remembers him inviting him and then he
didn't appreciate the TalkBack this is a
real moment
you didn't tell me that last time you
last time you shot me door you in my
life you told me last time to have lunch
with you now you change your mind to uh
old New York Jews battling look at this
he's not joking he's not doing the Jazz
fingers that's a serious moment yeah
yeah Jimmy's upset
oh my God
the funniest moment I've ever seen dude
I was dying I I find it interesting that
he even had the presence of mine to
upload that because like it's not funny
it's weird though I think it's really
[__] funny one of the funniest things
I've ever done the only funny thing I've
ever seen yeah yeah but isn't it just
more bizarre though like without any
context or just yelling at each other
well ask Eddie he doesn't have any of
the context okay Eddie give me your
unfiltered take on this that's a soup
you didn't tell me that last time you
last time you sat with me or you in my
life you told me last time to have lunch
with you now you change your mind yeah
that wasn't really getting uh the
realness you know and like you know he
didn't really plan this and he's getting
uh a lot of
Force ability on it so that you know it
doesn't seem like the person that he's
with you know was in on it with him oh
no no no that's as real as it gets oh
yeah and I mean Bernie Sanders has been
through a left an awful my God let the
man enjoy his suit by himself you're
doing too much Jimmy but the people love
it
yeah I'll have to get some ideas from
that that's good yeah probably not the
best place to go to be totally Frank
with you yeah also in other news
a neurologist actually uh on Tick Tock
was praising me for
um I had this debate with this guy Mark
Elliott from Nexium he said he cured
Tourette syndrome and I had this doctor
backing me up which was really nice to
see actually because
have a good night
it's just so weird that his claims like
I'm not sure is still what to make I
know there's deception in it but I'm
just not sure what to make of all the
claims here
but here's a neurologist who's actually
I guess pretty popular on tick tock
skeptic's guide I think you actually
think having turrets
yeah I don't think I think you actually
don't have it
well
so that was actually Ethan Klein from
the H3 podcast there who did a good job
uh exposing pushing back against Mark
Elliott thank you he was made quite the
career claiming that some technique he
used from a self-help cult uh helped him
get over his rather severe Tourette's
Syndrome I thought I'd chime in as a
neurologist to you know back up Ethan
actually there is no cure for Tourette's
there is no way to a hundred percent get
over or resolve or whatever euphemism
you know Mark wants to use to avoid the
Cure word but basically you can't
completely get rid of Tourette's it's
actually in you know built into the very
nature of Tourette's itself so what it
is is you know you you people who have
the Tourette Syndrome it could exist
with obsessive-compulsive disorder
anxiety add other you know neurological
disorders they have a compulsion to do
what we call a tick to do some kind of
behavior either a vocalization or a
physical movement the desire to do the
tick builds until they basically have to
do it and that relieves that Sensation
that they have to do it
by definition you can't consciously
control it you can't just will yourself
not to have those ticks it is treatable
it is manageable you could learn how to
you know you know reduce you know
triggering of the ticks you could learn
you could take medication to re reduce
them but there is no cure there is no
100 treatment the idea that you can use
any kind of self-help technique to
essentially cure it is you know dubious
to say the least it's you know in my
opinion completely thank you doctor that
they even did you know the cult did a
study the Nexium cult looking at their
technique and Tourette's the the doctor
who was who was leading that study
actually lost his license for doing
unethical research the people who were
involved in the study told horror
stories how it destroyed their
self-esteem and it was how destructive
it was for them
there is no self-help cure for
Tourette's it is that doesn't fit with
the with the Neuroscience with the
neurology don't believe it I don't
believe it at all
so did he play chestnuts at the end yeah
who is he
it's actually nice to have the backing
up there of a neurologist because I'm
not a doctor you know but uh this guy's
pretty cool Skeptics Guide so shout out
to doctor he doesn't have his name
Dr skeptic yeah he's a good guy have a
good night have a good night okay well
here Eddie so before my mom calls in to
unpack this drama I'm gonna run to the
bathroom real fast are you good yeah you
don't need anything do you need a drink
or snacks yeah okay I'll be right back
and then we'll hop into the next segment
let's do this yeah
oh no
what is this
wait a minute
get better better
well
yeah Amber Reno they
foreign
ERS the um
no I'm good thank you very much
a bit on water
oh yeah I put it uh behind the couch but
I'm good thank you very much
oh yeah maybe I'll just
get real quick
while we're sitting here okay perfect
let's go
all right
oh it is
just a fixed stays here and
um
okay perfect
no I'm ready
that's why I just stretch my legs a
little bit
okay
listen I want to sit here alone you
didn't tell me that last time you last
time you said we talked
sorry
about that
yeah
the foot soldiers and who else let's say
that they've nation football news
yeah it's a lot of fun I'm really
enjoying it it's very informational and
learning a lot and it's really fun to be
in the studio with you guys
Chad loves you oh thank you thank you so
much well I love them back and I've been
mentioning every now I'm really
following the comments and I'm I'm going
to be always saying you know yeah I
appeared on the H3 podcast so go on
YouTube and check it out and you know
I'll try to follow each comment because
I do get a lot of people that are asking
me to uh you know talking about the H3
podcast a lot in the comments and
so it's a good tie-in I really
appreciate all the exposure and I just
it's a dream thing to do you know
because for a long time I was not
blowing up on Tick Tock for like two
years I couldn't get from 12 10 000 to
12 000 followers and then it was only
January 17th of my birthday of this year
that it started to get a little bit busy
better you know
but until that time I couldn't go from
fourteen thousand it just stuck at 14
000 followers forever
and then January 17th when I started
doing a few shirtless videos that's when
it kind of uh now I have almost 70 000
followers and it's really been uh
phenomenal and I wanted to keep going
because I know this other lady that has
like 500 000 followers on there and
she's like
uh you know and people that you just
don't know how they got half a million
followers or like a million followers
and
well you know in the same time I've been
on there because I started before the
after right during the pandemic on there
and
so uh you know I hope it keeps
continuing but
if not it's okay but you know I really
enjoy the the little boost so far you
know sure and uh y'all have been really
good thank you for filming a video with
me too Eddie oh thank you yeah
do you usually not take requests like if
somebody wants to do a video with you oh
yes I I will do any requests they like
I've never said no and in fact somebody
gave me an idea yesterday about doing
like seven people in a store you know
any store and just have them all be
shirtless and I'd be the one with the
shirt on so I might start doing a shirt
on videos where I tell them no like I
tell them I wouldn't take my shirt off
just to like have a diversion from the
same old same old because I always like
to do variety I never like to stay on
the same thing
but it's been you know I used to do
singing on there and acting Duets and a
lot of singing Duets and uh one guy that
I follow a lot on there uh he got he got
to accompany Joss Stone a lot and then
another one got uh he got 500 000
followers by Billy eilish one time from
her bedroom with half of a light on did
a duet with him and he's a vocal coach
and ever since then I always I'm
promoting him constantly because I sing
a lot of duets with him and uh so uh
he's back in England and so I always
tell people you know follow this person
and at so and so and he's been dueted by
Billy eilish so you can duet with him
too so I'm always helping others promote
and I've always constantly sent people a
lot of and now I'm starting to tag you a
lot too in all my videos I'll put at H3
podcast because because you have a
following on there as well that P and I
know you only follow about 13 people but
I was a little miffed that you didn't
follow me but I know you may or may not
be able to because you know your first
person you follow is Howie Mandel and
then you have some others but you only
follow about 13 people so that's how
come I didn't get your instant messages
probably because I may have not been
able to follow you back because I only
have 10 000 follow people I can follow
on Tick Tock you can and I've always
told them you know I wish they could
just some of the JT Barrett there's this
guy named you might want to have him on
your show too JT Barnett he tried to do
a real house
for tick tock about three years ago when
the pandemic happened and they tried to
pay their rent of a a big house by uh
having like a tick tock uh real world
house like MTV
meets like you know uh Big Brother house
and I don't think it went it just never
caught on but they still do he
constantly texts me all the time I must
have signed up for his email list and
he's always texting me giving me these
motivational like I hope everything's
good today you rock or you'll do well
and I don't know if he's texting like
400 000 people at the same time then
there's another guy Justin shoot that
does Broadway he was on in Tina Turner
on Broadway he's on Tick Tock and what
happens with him is he started this
whole like group that he they pay him to
give you know for him to like motivate
them and uh you know now people are
starting to do subscriptions on Tick
Tock when you go live and I haven't done
that but to try to monetize because you
could pay like five dollars for all the
and if you have a subscription goal if
you get like 500 people following your
lives all the time and they pay five
dollars a month uh you you do the math
you know they can make money doing that
but I never really wanted to do that I
grew up doing community theater where we
were unpaid and I was in the saltines at
in my hometown they were like the San
Antonio Little Theater teen group and we
were like the per you know like they had
Kids Incorporated here in Los Angeles
and it was sort of like that we did a
lot of like before Glee type of stuff
you know
and we would Tour all over San Antonio
in the Riverwalk and do but it was
always unpaid and then I did a lot of
Community Theater that was unpaid too so
I don't mind it I really my mom always
said it was an honor to do it you know
and
and my parents weren't into Showbiz they
I got them involved in the theater
I like I then my mom became the box
office manager of the theaters that we
worked in in San Antonio and you know
they were San Antonio was mostly
military Hispanic Town five military
bases a lot of Latinos there like 80
percent Latino
and San Antonio's we don't have an ocean
there you know you have to go four hours
to Corpus Christi to an ocean
and so that's why I like La I came here
when I was you know 18 19 20 and
um you know uh the pay then was like
five dollars an hour from minimum wage
eight dollars an hour in the 80s and
then I used to do like telemarketing to
make ends meet and I worked as an intern
in my agent's office and she had like
how he she had like the Cosby kid one of
the Cosby Kids and Greg Kinnear she had
Greg Kinnear and he I would sit in the
office and you know in her on a desk and
answer phones and I'd say artists first
artists first and my agent liked the way
I said artists first you know she
thought that I was proud of being in
that agency and my commercial agent
would always say you know you're in the
you're in the receptionist here at the
office uh and you never know who could
come in at any moment you know
and Greg Kinnear came in one time and I
used to watch him on the prime time
Channel it was before the e-channel
every day you know after I'd get home
from either an acting class or my
agent's office or whatever it was
telemarketing job and I'd watch The
Prime Time Movie Channel but Greg
Kinnear wasn't even signed theatrically
with her she would only take him on
commercially
and then he got As Good As It Gets and
he gets an Academy Award supporting
actor domination
but I asked him while I was on the desk
you know hey Greg I really loved you on
your Primetime movie channel uh and he
uh he goes thanks thanks a lot
and I uh then like yeah we would have
like the the maid that killed Selena
Lupe antiviros and we had like uh one of
the 21 Jump Street kids because uh she
handled a lot of the ethnic Talent when
nobody in LA in 85 would high end it was
mostly white bread and they wouldn't
hire like they wouldn't handle like
blacks Hispanics and Asians but she was
like one of the first Trailblazers to
like have authenticities in her roster
but back then you know it was like I
lived in beverlywood subdivision and uh
I was renting a room downstairs in a
pool room you know by the pool and right
across the street you know the the they
would call that neighborhood the jungle
and Beverly Hood subdivision was like
where the black people didn't go you
know and like if they crossed the street
they would say go back to your jungle
over there so it was kind of D not as
even though la has always been
good to the ethnics it was like not
always that way there was still a lot of
racism even back then in 85.
but we had Malcolm Jamal Warner of The
Cosby Show and Justin mcguyen from 21
Jump Street and Greg Kinnear and in our
rosters I used to pick pictures for like
you know back then and
like for Morgan Fairchild I would you
know and then back then when I came to
town in 85 they had peewee's big
adventure and was out in the movies and
I did a lot of auditions for like
Revenge of the Nerds part two and you
know there were a lot of uh nerdy roles
you could try out for and and I did do a
Shakey's Pizza commercial for it was a
National Commercial and they flew me to
Minneapolis Minnesota and I got to do
that and that was exciting
and you get to back then they would fly
people first class as an actor you know
even if you were in a commercial or
something
and I told my agent you know we're stuck
here for three days in a blizzard and uh
Rhoda Gem and Yani from the who's the
boss is here uh she's my she was playing
my mom or something her aunt it was for
an all you can eat Shakey's Pizza buffet
commercial and I said uh she was the
reason they didn't go longer and I could
have made a million dollars doing it and
get a Malibu house was because she had
been like the that she was like the
spokesperson for Ragu back in the late
70s and early 80s so when Shakey's Pizza
hired her
they probably realized she was the Ragu
lady and it could have been a conflict
you know
but I auditioned with one of the Mrs
Kravitz from Bewitched to get on that
Shakey's Pizza commercial and it was me
and Mrs Kravitz
the real Mrs Kravitz or the last one
they had three Mrs Kravitz on Bewitched
and uh it was fun being back then in the
85 times because when I first came to
town because we had the We Are the World
had just come out you know and so it was
like the We Are the World kind of times
you know and it was fun because back
then you had a lot of the rock and roll
you know Ralphs and The Rock and Roll
kind of vibe going on in La you know it
was really burgeoning
and uh yeah back then
in the 90s and I've been here in the
2000s and 2010s and then 2020s but it's
a whole different ball game now the
streaming and everything else oh yeah
but uh yeah some good times
yeah I was in a lot of classic movies
show girls I was in Showgirls I was
there the day that Elizabeth Berkeley
was getting manhandled and fondled by
the director Paul verhoven in a scene we
did at uh Raleigh Studios in Hollywood
it was back then it was the Formosa
Studios you know or one of those where
they filmed Dynasty after they moved it
from 20th Century Fox and I was on
Dynasty one time with Blake Carrington
on a beach scene in Malibu with a I had
to hire a German Shepherd dog from sag
you know to get like a
a trainer to bring the dog to the set to
get the job and back then you know I
played a football player on Married with
Children and a basketball player on
Fresh Prince of Bel Air and never played
basketball or football before
but you know back then you just threw on
a uniform and you played the basketball
or you played football
and
um got to work with Kirk Douglas and
Eric Douglas one time when they were
blowing up like World War One scenes
with land mines and I couldn't stand it
because they were blowing things up
around us so I faked uh being sick and I
had to go to the the med uh they had a
medic uh you know one of those
ambulances the onset and so I they made
me drink six gallons of Gatorade
thinking I was dehydrated just so I
wouldn't have to work in that scene
where they were blowing up land mines
but I did China Beach for two years with
Dana Delany and mark helgenberger from
CSI and had to wear GI Soldier outfit
and you know grease all over my face
every day and oil you know and then they
would blow you up they'd blow put squids
on you and blow things up and I got PST
PTSD from working on that for two years
wow because there was a lot of like
sitting in trenches while they blew up
and having to run around blow up scenes
and and helicopters and like you know
you had to actually be Vietnam War
people and they made it look real and
right next to us was filming another
series about Vietnam and so I had to be
like a Vietnam War soldiers and then
like for um TV shows like the X-Files we
had to run on top of like roofs but one
of my favorites too was like seven with
Brad Pitt and uh where I had to be like
a SWAT team coming in and out of a truck
you know and really being SWAT and being
like hustling to get in and out of that
SWAT truck
and a lot of times you had to carry
around a lot of you had to be a
policeman on sets with guns and all the
different accoutrements from the guns
and this and the police uniform
and my very first extra job I got to
actually be a cop and have speaking
lines as a cop and read the Miranda
rights to one of the White Castle guys
and uh with James Spader and that was
fun working with him
and Rob well a lot of the Rob Lowe TV
movies and TV shows and then well I did
five uh Jim Carrey movies five Adams
seven or eight Adam Sandler movies
where you know once they used you and
Adam Sandler knew you you'd work on it
from time to time a different uh
so those were fun they're volcano
Dante's Peak Independence Day I got to
read lines with like Jeff Goldblum from
from Independence Day is a he I helped
him practice lines of Independence Day
you know while we were there on set
waiting around for the because there's a
lot of down time
or going into trailers of actresses and
going and doing soap operas where you're
helping them with their lines that
they're going to 80 pages of dialogue
like right now I'm supposed to go right
after this to a a play that I got where
they're going to put together a one-man
show and so I'm thinking you know they
have no script but we'll have to just
like improvise it
and they're going to film it I think for
they're trying to sell it to a network
on how to hire an actor and do a one-man
show all of a sudden like in four hours
but uh yeah a lot of it uh I've been
played a lot of aliens I've played uh
one time for you know where you had to
wear a full alien like head for uh like
you know different TV shows and it pulls
on your neck sometimes the Prosthetics
that they put it pulls on your neck a
lot or it hurts your you know up here it
pulls hair one of my last jobs recently
was like a basketball drama for a
streaming channel in which we had to
wear wigs and pins in our hair and it
was 70s oh and I got to work with Jay
Leno recently on a a movie that he
played uh Ed uh you know from the Ed
Sullivan
that was fun and and uh Jay I got to
work with him on a few episodes a lot of
episodes of his uh you bet your life and
you got to ask questions and he always
talks a lot you know dirt tall the
audience and and even between takes and
he never leaves the set and he's we're
sitting there and we go on restroom
breaks but he like stays there the whole
time and entertains people but my
favorite job was on bird cage with Robin
Williams and uh there were drag queens
that were dancing in like in between
takes and like out in the parking lot
you have hours to sit there and wait
till they set up the you know and like
Nichols of a big director and sometimes
you get to be in scenes that are cut in
the movie and then Robin Williams kept
entertaining Us in between tanks and he
was like his mom came to the set and we
got to eat with his mom and him and he
was very serious off camera but then
when he's ready in the set he was very
comedic and constantly on and constantly
entertaining us and making sure we're
all all like having a great time and it
was so shocking the difference when he
goes to eat lunch he's totally serious
and with his mom and serious and like
totally night and day he had a
personality that was like happy one
minute and like not depressed but just
very serious and Stern the next minute
you know what after he's away from the
set and another fun one I did was with
Roseanne and Tom Arnold in which she
used to turn her seats away from the set
and Taryn Tom Arnold and I got to lay
down on like a carpet with her like she
would put a beach towel down and
and just sit there on the floor like you
know and we're wondering is she was no
Miss Hollywood like we thought she would
be you know it's just
but that was fun and the Connors I got
to be in the audience a lot of
the Connors and they recently asked me
to be like a mascot on uh on that mass
singer
yeah you had to go in for a wardrobe
fitting and go in and like be fit and I
think it was going to be for me to like
maybe double Amber Riley because at the
time I was bigger
and maybe she had a big frame and they
didn't want to disrespect her and like
have a man a woman play her that was
bigger so they asked a man to like fit
into her sizes or something but I used
to work on Glee a lot and that was fun I
got to work with uh I saw you had a
picture of Adam Lambert and I got to do
a lot of dance scenes with him and and
one time I was on the set with uh well
Leah Michelle and Eric Eric Stoltz from
Back to the Future directed a lot of
episodes and he would come up to me and
say hi I'm Eric Stoltz I says I and I
told him yes I know who you are oh yeah
I adore you and respect you and and I
got to work on a few movies of his
before he was going to go uh I mean
after he had lost the part on Back to
the Future Part Two like in the 80s and
90s but he was a good director for a
director and actor from The Mask
But Eric Stoltz directed a lot of Glee
episodes and Glee was my favorite show
to work on that and 90210 in Beverly and
uh and the original Melrose Place I got
to work on a lot of Melrose Place a lot
of that I proposed to Tori Spelling on
the set of 90210. she said yes
she actually said yes it was before she
got married and she goes yes right away
she's no hesitation because I said I
really did like her it wasn't that I
just wanted to marry a spelling you know
I did like her I like Randy spelling I
followed him a lot on when he was first
on Tick Tock and as well he lives in
Portland I think and uh recently I've
been following Danny pintaro he might
even come on your show but he couldn't
get it past 12 like 8 000 followers even
though he's a TV star
they weren't uh giving him enough love
and he and I went on his page and was
telling him about the ins and outs of
why I felt similar and he couldn't
follow his and he was telling me Oh yes
that's not uh that's just unacceptable
that you know but the main beef was that
he couldn't get enough followers even
though he was a TV star from who's the
boss and I used to work on who's the
boss a lot with Dan I got to do a few uh
things with uh you know Danny DeVito I
recently worked with Danny DeVito and on
oh one of my favorites too recently was
I got to be a cameraman on
um on the pool man with uh Chris Pine
that was one of the extra jobs that I
enjoyed and I got featured recently
where I got to be in the movie there was
a shed movie though it was horrible but
Chris Pine he's like one of my favorite
actors I got to see him in a play you
know at the uh David Geffen Playhouse
and my god well Chris Pine from Star
Trek you know Shatner
and uh but I did uh work with them on
that movie and I thought it was going to
be like a funny comedy but it turned out
it was more like a psychological drama
but at the time when we were doing it
you know it seemed like he should have
made it a really funny comedy but he
directed it and wrote it Chris Pine it
was called the pool man it was recent
that was fun to work on
because uh you got to work with an ed
Benning and you know Annette Benning I
did the the my the president I did the
American president with her and well
when you get directed by like Rob Reiner
that's always fun I got to work on
Mississippi Burning with you know with
Rob Reiner and of course you know uh
Alec Baldwin that was fun poor Al
Baldwin though huh
what happened to him but you know a lot
of times when you're on the sets they
are sometimes you worry about the safety
sometimes and that lady you know there
was a young girl that didn't kind of put
in the bullets properly or they didn't
test them
but Alec Baldwin when he was saying you
know
am I aiming it right at the camera am I
aiming it am I aiming it it was sort of
a little suspect but the thing was is
that
he was trying to look cool that's the
problem he's getting older and his he
even said that he before that shooting
happened he had said that his eyes were
getting puffy very puffy and they get
very uh when you know you're aging he
was a gla he was a hot guy on Knott's
Landing but then when he started aging
and he gets terrible puffiness of his
eyes here and there he's very sensitive
to how he's going to look on camera and
that was what his fault was that's what
caused the whole situation because he
was trying to aim it to where he would
look as cool as possible holding a gun
because he didn't want to look weird and
wacky he had to look sort of like you
know how Liam Neeson looks holding a gun
or other people and that could have been
the problem plus rust was a very very
low budget production and they're still
filming and they're ending finishing it
but they moved to a different like whole
place you know to do Rust another Ranch
but wife you know they'd have to finish
it because now they'll be interest in
the movie
to see you know people will go see it
like when they saw you know the guy from
Batman when the guy died Heath Ledger
everybody went to see that movie so
there would be like Rebel Without a
Cause to see when James Dean died his
last movie you know
but uh it'll be curious to see if rust
does any business
but it might you know it'll probably be
a cult classic because of what happened
but I wonder if Alec Baldwin is going to
be lynched and mobbed over it you know
and is he going to have to serve jail
time and all that
but a lot of times the um
you know on sets there have been times
when I felt unsafe too and you know
there's nothing you can do because you
you wonder are you going to die over it
you know so I've actually gone to the
emergency trailers and telling them you
know like I did on that one world war
one picture when they're blowing up land
mines I didn't want to like get injured
so and I stopped working on China Beach
because I finally caved in and told them
you know I was sitting in a trench while
they were going to blow it up and I
finally told them I can't take this
anymore and we're when you're there 18
19 20 hours a day and you're making
golden time is what you said what golden
time was yeah you know it's like that's
great but you know you know it's just
psychologically getting on you it's
wearing and tearing on you and finally
chip if you sell like or whoever was the
PA or ads no A.D first ad on the show
finally just said well okay Eddie get
out of there and then I didn't work on
the show much anymore
because you can't say no to them they
want you in that particular area and
they want you and there's nothing you
can do you really can't say no as an
extra you know like if you were an actor
you have choices but if you're in an
extra when they place you you can't just
make you know direct yourself you have
to but nowadays like oh and then I just
work recently on one where I was in an
airport scene where all the airport
scenes are usually shot at like the LA
Convention Center and people like
working there because it's a lot better
than working at a real airport so I just
recently did one called rap [__] that
was there it was called rap [__] that
was my last job rap [__] it was just
about three four weeks ago and I that's
good that I remembered that now because
I haven't been paid for it yet but you
have to call the payroll company because
everything's digital now and sometimes
you don't fill out vouchers and so you I
have to call them because uh when you
get there your stage name is for sag is
different than it is for your for your
screen name or something like that
but uh generally nowadays it's laid back
and you can do it even if you're sagged
because non-union if you want to or sag
because they look away from it unless
you have an actual speaking part and so
forth but before you know people would
all be worried that oh you might not be
able to what if you lose your sag card
over it but why I've defended a Casting
Company several times when sag called me
to say Hey you worked on a coke
commercial or Pepsi commercial with or
about T-Mobile one of the mobile
companies with the Boris Bend It Like
Beckham the guy Beckham John that's
married to the Spice Girl
and they called and said you worked for
BTS and uh you why were you non-union
that day and I and you know BTS told
them at sag that there were no numbers
the SAG doesn't increase the numbers of
the Screen Actors Guild people to be
paid union wages so they have the union
has to work non-union but the non-union
pay could be like 250 for the day and
the union pay for her Union commercial
could be 350 366 dollars so it's not
much difference and for that you'd
rather work than not make zero and so I
I defended BTS because even though they
don't work me much sag still I I felt
like you know they work you at least and
they are work they're hard-working
Agency for extras so I told sag a thing
or three and that shut them up I told
them you know there's no numbers you're
not increasing your numbers and they
were no numbers that day and she told
you that originally and it said in the
letter that they sent to me you know if
you do that you could have possibly have
lost your sad card and I they because
but we were told because there were no
numbers that day that's why you worked
non-union that's what so what is your
take on that and I had to tell them you
know I defended the people I work with
because it's like but other extras would
not do that they would chastise that
company and that's why that happened in
order to like think they can just get a
sag pay that day or an upgrade
but if they hire you and you're at that
pay you know it's not their fault all
the time there is nepotism there is
favoritism sometimes but not all the
time
and I realize you know that they had at
least they hired you know 500 extras so
they could only hire a hundred Union but
still they hired 400 other non-union
extras so
like I had to work Euphoria and all
non-union and when I got there Zendaya
she had her tennis shoe laces untied for
the whole time I mean she never tied her
tennis shoes and she was real frumpy
looking normally she's a glamor puss but
she had to wear like you know really
baggy clothes and kind of look frumpy
for Euphoria and we were doing a theater
scene where we were in the audience and
I was in the first or second row and
there's you know
uh Zendaya and she's all walking around
or sitting on the stage with her tennis
shoe laces untied and I get constantly
ribbed for having my tennis shoelaces
untied so whenever anyone says that I
always say well I'm like Zendaya we
don't Tire tennis shoes it's an
attention grabber we don't have to tie
our tennis shoes why don't you talk to
Zendaya about that she doesn't Tire
tennis shoes
but some people don't it's like who
decreed that you have to retire tennis
shoes constantly I mean I get told by a
friend of mine who I walked the dog with
on Chandler in my home you know in
Burbank oh your tennis shoes untied and
I have to say like you know who decree
oh my God
what's going to happen if the tennis
shoes are untied oh
you know I don't have to tie them why
don't you tie them or like if I'm on the
set sometimes I'll tell the Wardrobe but
I get sick of them telling me uh you
have to tie your tie or tie your tie
that's how they talk they just say it
bluntly like tie your tie and I usually
tell them you know I was like one of
those clip tie Clipper persons that
already had a clip you know you just
clip it on clip on ties and I don't tie
ties I never learned I don't care and so
I go like what is this you tired you're
the Wardrobe people what's going on you
go ahead and tie it they're paying you
to be the Wardrobe could you do it for
me this guy doesn't have a shirt on
hello how are you yes I'm here I'm
shirtlessetti I do Tick Tock videos with
my shirt off it's been going viral so
that's why I've been deciding to do it
and that's why Ethan saw me or somebody
saw me on Tick Tock one of your the crew
members here and how are you nice to
meet you uh basically it's just a a
thing that I do you know I've been
recently getting more followers on Tick
Tock so I like it because it's just
because you know you can be more free in
La a little more laid back and also I
lost weight I lost 33 pounds in three
weeks on the field grade system and so I
figured I want to show my before and
after pictures I really do and so I've
lost I I gained I lost weight I was 269
pounds when I started three and a half
weeks ago now I'm 200 and like 40 237
pounds and my goal is to go to 200 or
198. but also I'm curbing my diabetes my
cholesterol my blood sugar when and down
my high blood pressure I have more
energy more stamina more confidence and
it's all because of one drink you drink
in the morning and then 10 minutes
before you eat a meal you drink another
little drink and you can eat two meals a
day but I did Fast it's like Yom Kippur
I fasted uh every day now I'm making up
for the times I didn't fast in Yom
Kippur because it's a you just fast at
night eight hours a night and then four
hours in the morning you just don't eat
a breakfast but at 1 pm or 5 p.m you can
eat your breakfast if you want and you
can eat it's food freedom and so uh you
know it's a little drink called the
field grade system I met somebody on
Tick Tock I saw their videos and he they
he used to run or be the CEO of like
Herbalife or some company but Unicity by
unit they're called unicities I thought
they were unionist city but they're
called Unicity balance and Unicity you
unamate and it's the Yerba made plant
from South America it's all natural
there's no sugar in it it's 360
uh times more chlorogenic acid that's
found in coffee and I don't drink coffee
and I don't I used to drink hot tea or
cold tea I don't drink coffee so that's
why the chlorogenic acid is burning my
fat it gives you stamina it's willpower
in a packet and it's only five dollars a
day and now everybody on Tech talk is
selling it but I I didn't become a
distributor I'm just a raving fan an
actor and singer and so I I lost weight
on it and I can fit into some clothes
that are for the Wardrobe Department
because they're all low budget right now
and they don't really have sizes over
like a 42 or 44 waist and now I can fit
into shirts extra large and before I was
a 2XL just three weeks ago four weeks
ago so it really works and it just burns
off your fat while you eat foods and
used to lose weight so I really enjoy it
and I have I only sold one kid to
somebody it's only like five dollars a
day but if they sell it to someone else
then they would make ten dollars and if
you pay fifty dollars you become a
distributor and you can sell the kids
and every kid you sell to somebody for
147 dollars they get 20 you get twenty
five dollars right now I just get a
credit on my account
but it's worth it because what your
health is worth you know if I get
neuropathy it kills your neuropathy pain
it kills your your inflammation it's oh
it's a fiber Matrix so what happens is I
haven't had to urinate as much I don't
go I used to go frequently I don't have
to I'm 56 years old so now as a with on
this field grade system I don't have to
urinate but you know at a regular basis
I don't have to go every five seconds to
the restroom because I'm not insulin I'm
not bathing in insulin anymore it's
insulin I'm insulin uh where before I
was insulin resistant now I'm that's
burning the food for fuel
so it works it's I've been happy with it
and I never tried a diet I never went on
those JoJo diets but none of them were
and so I might have tried one one The
Zone perfect diet years ago and that was
food that they would bring you'd order
and they'd leave it on your front
doorstep but I thought they put
something in the food back then and
because it was making me loopy
or something like in 2003 or something
it was called The Zone perfect diet and
it was only in LA and it was like you
know before they had like the meal kits
or veal plans like you know now they
have the Martha stewards and the you
know the food meal kits now that you can
either cook or have them like TV dinners
that you throw in the microwave or or
the air hydrators or whatever they're
called and so now I really like it it's
called The Field grade system and I just
put the website on my little bio and
Tick Tock but I don't really push it
that much there are other it's just two
boxes you get 60 days of the balance
fire Matrix and you get 30 day supply of
the of the or it's a herbal tea not a
herbal tea but it's like a lemon tea and
you can choose your flavors lemon tea or
you can have black like coffee or you
can have ginger Citrus for the for in
the morning you just drink it in a
little shaker bottle and you don't have
to even use a blender you just take the
packet and you throw it in the little
thing and you sip on it whenever you
feel hungry but it curbs your appetite
and it extends your fast and it's like
every day is Yom Kippur because I only
found last for eight hours a night when
I go to sleep and four hours in the
morning and then I can eat anything I
want at one o'clock or five o'clock it's
food freedom but it also helps your I'm
not going to have a heart attack now
from diabetes and soon I'll be off of
metformin and Glipizide
so the pills instead of taking the pills
when you drink the drink it helps you
and allows you all these people have
been off of the pills now of the
Glipizide metformin and they're also off
high blood pressure medication and all
the statins and all that so I don't know
you can check it out it's called the
field grade system it's by Unicity and
everybody's on Tick Tock now I see a lot
of people all of a sudden eight or nine
people are starting to like push it but
the one man that I saw on there I just
was motivated by his videos because it
showed the before and after pictures and
his face was wider and his body was
wider and now it shrunk you know and he
looks younger and he's 69 years old and
he can actually go and bench press and
he can go to the gym if he wants he had
neuropathy pain so bad that he couldn't
walk hardly now he's doing exercises at
the gym and I too didn't go to the gym
for the last 10 years because my
aerobics teacher going there and she
went to Marina del Rey
and it was too far from me from the
valley to schlep all the way to Marina
del Rey but now and I used to take
aerobics three times a week and I also
took with Richard Simmons Rich Simmons
Richard Simmons or whatever it was
called and he was a weird one the and I
love him to death but when I worked I
did uh when I went to his Studio to work
out he had two female bathrooms which is
okay with me I don't care what they do
but it was just more you know he was
catering more to women I understand that
but he did have a lot of men in there
too that would take his aerobics and I
would wear short shorts when I would go
to his classes sort of like because
bikini should like shorts just because
that was what he was dancing as and we
would like dance around to like back
then it was like you know like uh
that uh there was uh the Christina
Aguilera share movie just came out so we
would dance a lot to the songs from that
movie burlesque and but basically
Richard Simmons when nowhere he went out
the door I don't know if you could get
him in here but he like where did he go
he disappeared he kind of went wacko for
some reason he kind of went crazy and
now all of a sudden you don't see or
hear from him but when I was on the
Bonnie Hunt show I was it was like a
Mary Tyler Moore sitcom and I got to be
a featured extra and I was on a desk
right next to Bonnie Hunt for like 13
episodes and it was before they did the
where they built the Grove and they had
just built a few new Studios at CBS and
anyway Bonnie Hunt was in that Dave
movie where she goes and we're walking
we're walking and then she was in you
know Cheaper by the Dozen and she was in
Jumanji with uh Robin Williams I think
it was well anyway Bonnie had I loved
her she was like before Jane Lynch was
so popular Bonnie Hunt was popular and
then all of a sudden and they took
together at second City Bonnie Hunt and
Jane Lynch but then Shane Lynch got the
TV series You Know Glee and where did
Bonnie Hunt go but she's done a few
streaming TV series but I loved her I
really did I liked her a lot and she was
funny but she came on when Seinfeld had
just come on for the first two years on
CBS and David Letterman produced her
and what happened was they had an affair
and David Letterman would come and fly
all the way from New York before he
would do his talk show at night he'd fly
there just to go into her dressing room
and they'd have say they would be making
out together and they were both married
at the time
David Letterman had not divorced yet and
also Bonnie Hunt's husband he got a lot
of stock with American online and she
would tell us on this set my husband's
wasting all my money buying stock in
American online I just know something's
going to go wrong we're going to lose it
all and you know then later two three
years later American online kind of
Tanked they thought they were going to
be the next Time Warner had bought them
or they kind of merged you know with
Time Warner and they thought they were
going to be a big and what happened to
America online but I was with them for
many years are you and uh so it was fun
you know to work on that sitcom and I
did a lot of sitcoms I was there when
Leo DiCaprio was a little kid on Growing
Pains and I got to stand right next to
uh you know Kirk Cameron in between
takes and before we would go on to the
set and Kirk was so jealous of Leo
DiCaprio it was seethingly upset that
that Leo was taking his Thunder
because and then Kirk fired his girl
then on-screen girlfriend because she
was a Playboy centerfold and Kirk was
too you know prim and proper and he was
just getting into the pritican diet and
I used to take gifts that I would uh
bring the scripts from the trailers of
some of the growing pains kids and I
would actually they'd ask me to go get
the script for them and we would uh
practice lines in between takes that was
a lot of fun or working on Growing Pains
you know that was fun and uh
yeah those were the good old days but
you know uh recently I've done a lot of
TV shows and movies it's just that
there's they're only do eight episodes
of these streaming shows so you don't
get a chance to like really you know get
to work on it long enough you might only
work one or two episodes when before
they would do like 39 episodes you know
but I did do Gray's Anatomy a lot I
worked on that show a lot recently and
Through the Years
I got to do their 200th episode with
Patrick Dempsey and I did work on some
movies with Patrick Dempsey as well and
and that was fun you know to work with
him and some of the old 80s and 90s
stars and
and um well Pierce Brosnan put his arm
around me on a couch in the lawnmower
man why you know he did that in between
the time he was double 07.
and uh that was funny he goes what's up
and he had his arm around me for quite a
long time during when we did the
lawnmower man two or something like that
and sometimes oh my favorite one to work
on was uh now it's bringing back
memories was I did the Centipede Human
Centipede 3 and I had to be a human
centipede on the floor stuck head to the
Ted to groin with males in a centipede
line and the raunchy director's language
that she used it was so raunchy and so
dirty you talk F words and you talk but
this was like porno talk the way she was
talking and it was so raunchy that Eric
Roberts off screen was laughing about
how raunchy it was I mean he was just
laughing his head off because he
produced I think centipede three but we
had to be human centipedes and that was
fun to be like head to Ted to butt head
to butt and they go get in there here
get in there put your head next to that
butt get in there and then and and don't
move and put your head right closer to
the butt to the butt crack and they
would talk so raunchy the dirty and
director was like getting into all
because because that movie Human
Centipede the dialogue in the script if
you watch that movie is very raunchy
dirty talk
and I think she really got into it the
female director you know from that movie
and sometimes the directors uh they get
into that you know I played a bouncer
one time on a C Thomas Howell movie
and it was uh that that particular
director kept calling me a couple of
times back because he liked and I'm not
don't look like a bouncer but I got to
like tell people stand back don't be
around this River velvet Road nobody
gets around this Velvet Rope or whatever
it was and I had to have dialogue you
know they just threw you dialogue or if
you're in a bar scene they might throw
you some dialogue but I have found that
when you're an extra if you're in the
right time at the right place you get
more lines than you do when you audition
really it's just the because of the fact
that they throw in extra stuff that
they're going to need or somebody didn't
show up or you're just like the right
type at the right time you know I have
another friend who on Facebook
constantly puts an arrow towards
everything he's ever been in until like
put an arrow and he puts like every
single little thing he's ever been in
he'll like post it on Facebook and you
could get in trouble for doing that
because you're not supposed to share it
on social media some of the things
you're in right away because then people
could see it before it happens
because Rosie O'Donnell got in trouble
one time on her talk show or she didn't
get in trouble but they got very upset
with her when she revealed she spoiled
no spoiler alert for Fight Club the
movie I was in with with meatloaf and we
were shirtless in a fight club scene and
she told the audience before the movie
came out the ex all the whole synopsis
of the movie and how it ended and the
studio got upset and Brad I think Brad
Pitt got very upset with her over that
but she she kind of divulged that she
didn't like that movie and what's really
weird is she's into ww she's into the
fighters you know the UFC she'll watch
the UFC fights all the time so but back
then maybe she just wasn't into UFC at
that time but see Fight Club was very
violent in her opinion about the you
know people getting all beat up and
abused and bruised up because of the
fact that they were bullied you know as
part of the joke on the fight club or
the thing to that they were told to do
their assignment
so that was and I didn't I used to watch
the Rosie O'Donnell show and I of course
when she came to La I watched it but I
understand that she got into some
squabble over the fact that she revealed
the ending of a movie before it came out
but you know that's the way it is she's
a nice girl she follows me on Tick Tock
Rosie O'Donnell and um
you know there's there's other people
that I've helped uh I used to push her
merch line I used to she did a t-shirt
line called Rosie freaking O'Donnell and
the merch line was made by
sniffapickle.com forward slash Rosie so
like I'm doing with the shirtless videos
I used to do for Rosie O'Donnell I would
countless people I would go and say hey
what do you think of Rosie O'Donnell
could you say Rosie freaking O'Donnell
on camera just say hey I mesmerized by
your shirt what does it say Rosie
freaking O'Donnell and I would get like
thousands of maybe a 400 500 people to
say hey I like your shirt what does it
say and they would read what said on my
shirt it said Rosie freaking O'Donnell
and a lot of them thought that she was
Rosie Roseanne Barr
or you know and I had to tell him no
she's not Roseanne Bar or you know type
of thing but I used to push her merch
line
a lot and I that's why she followed me
because a lot of the people that saw
that I was pushing her merch line would
like say at Rosie at Rosie at Rosie on
my comments in my posts because
countless people I would push her merch
line and then when she did the L word or
she and she got to do a bowling scene
she didn't even have me come on as a
bowler but I did get speaking lines on a
bowling movie with one of the guys from
the French guy from uh you know from the
Entourage one of the Entourage kids uh
guys the uh I was doing a bowling movie
one time and I was like an independent
movie it wasn't a bully movie but that
was our scene and the director happened
to be from one of those old NBC dramas
like the profiler or something like that
from NBC and she liked me she was a
blonde lady and she had just happened to
like me
sometimes the directors they just get a
feel for you when you first walk on to
them and they kind of like you and but
she seemed to like me for some reason
and then she said Eddie you're going to
have speaking lines today I want you to
say this and this and this and I want
you to also grab the guy from the
Entourage and pull him away from you so
I had to get a stunt coordinator guy to
show me how I could like pull him away
when he was going to have a fight with
another guy on the set and I had to put
my arms around him and like pull him
away from another guy in the scene for
some reason and I had to like learn the
stunt moves and things like that on how
to like or he's going to punch you out
and we need to have you know how to like
do it but not look too fake but then but
he's not really going to punch you but
you're going to go like this and then
this is how you throw it when they throw
a punch you're going to go like that and
things like that you have to sometimes I
was on another thing where they oh my
God the stunt people are the stunt
coordinators have to show you what
you're going to be doing because they
want it to look so real
and so that was fun working with one of
the Entourage guys and then one of the
the guys from White Castle the movie or
whatever oh Keenan that went about the
the two guys coulomb and Kemar or what's
his name kulam Harold and Kumar one of
the Harold and Kumar guys one time I was
a cop and I had to put handcuffs around
him and like put the actual handcuffs on
him and and like give him the Rand to
rights and then I had to like lock the
key the director said and put him on him
and then and put your little key in
there and make sure they're real tight
and he was like freaking out because I
put the the little handcuffs on him the
guy that was one of the herald or Kim
kumars he wasn't freaking out but he was
like playing with me to make it look
like it was like a fetish thing and like
he was like maybe traumatized by maybe
in real life he had had sex and he had
the little handcuffs thrown on him for
sex scene or something and maybe that
brought back sense memory because he was
trying to be a dramatic actor and that I
think who's this over here there's
somebody over there with a Mickey Mouse
and he's got his shirt off and uh so is
basically are you the mom of um of the
Ethan are you yeah
uh where what city are you in I'm I'm in
Woodland Hills OH Woodland Hills
California very good so we're just
waiting for Ethan to interview you I I
guess I don't know what's going on you
certainly I just want to say I hate the
rape I hate the rain I hate the [__]
awesome we uh hates the rain they hate
the rain that he hates the rain great
well you know uh
this one lady I know was upset with
Howie Mandel because she went on the
they went on that show you know the uh
NBC's the uh is uh America's Got Talent
and I think what happened was they were
the three grandmothers or something and
uh Howie extra gave her the X thing and
uh even though she kind of thought she
had made friends with him and then she
follows him but he doesn't follow her
back or something so she was kind of
like a little miffed you know with him
she and then she went on The Price is
Right and she didn't get all the way to
the they didn't the three grandmothers
went on The Price is Right and they also
lost and so that was number two of you
know them being traumatized hey there's
Ethan he's in a car what are you doing
are you uh driving out and about
Ethan's in the car looks like or is that
a previous video
he's in his car with his sunroof
where in the world is Ethan
Klein today
oh my gosh Dan what's going on
not much was going on with you
[Laughter]
you know Selena is I worked with on
Wizards of Waverly Waverly placement
what the heck
he can't hear you
oh my God the Wi-Fi could be out
Ethan you are too much
but no I think I work uh did uh Selena's
been good but she's from my hometown and
I saw her little documentary did you see
her documentary on Netflix she had a big
documentary on Netflix and it did real
well and uh have you seen the new Pamela
Anderson documentary about Pamela I have
not I worked on VIP and I got to be a
drummer and my friend was his his father
was the vice president of Sony and he
was the one that gave the tape to Tommy
batola for Mariah Carey to be a big you
know get her recording deal but anyway
Jerry and uh my friend Vinnie uh we got
to work together and a band scene in VIP
which was uh Pamela Anderson's second
show after Baywatch and then she had
another show call it which was about
videotapes or something it was on Fox
where she worked in like a blockbuster
and that got canceled but VIP was on for
three seasons or four seasons and it did
real well it was like a Charlie's Angels
but it was like with VIP
it was called very important person
anyway one day I was on set and she was
uh had just had another boob enlargement
and she was like hunched over and in
pain you know from having Dad having her
jugs were too big at the moment but I
didn't say anything but I could tell she
was in a little bit of pain you know but
she was a really pretty girl back then
and I've been watching her documentary
and it's really sentimental and fun
but she's not as big of a beauty as she
used to be but you know I think if she
just puts the black eyeliner around her
eye she looks like Pamela Anderson again
like when it's like putting the black
eyeliner off of Joan Collins it's just
that's her trademark she has to have the
black eyeliner and a lot of times women
don't want to put the black eyeliner on
anymore and that it's going to make them
look a little different but because of
the newer styles of today's makeup they
want to be natural
you know so I understand that but Pamela
Anderson's new Doc is really good and
Selena's dock was very good it was you
know she had a lot of her health issues
and and of course you know she she had a
lot of different uh things you know for
one movie she looked flat chested it was
a movie that she did which was a famous
book or something and she looked very
flat chested but you know that's it's
okay she was growing she was young at
the time
um they can't all have boob jobs not all
actresses can have boob jobs and you
know want to do that anymore now they're
just whoever they are
but Ethan's away he left the studio
I wonder if this is on live what we're
doing right now or what's going on this
was a surprise
we were told we were going to be he's
getting some fast food it looks like can
I get a uh
a number two please
a medium see I'm supposed to do a
one-man show at three o'clock but I'll
stay you know I'll just tell him I can
be late and then what do you want yeah
what time is it now it must be about 4
30. french fries two o'clock
three oh and then what do you think
okay I'll just get like uh
no Peppers
yes please
uh two Quarter Pounders maybe like a
bunch of McNuggets
and then oh my God what's the biggest
McNuggets I can't eat any fast food
because I'm on that field grade system
unless I drink my drink 10 minutes
before and I haven't had fast food since
the time I've been can I get a 40 piece
show
okay and then oh oh and then can I get
like uh
like five large french fries
it should be enough right yeah
maybe I should just get hamburgers
instead
there's a bus there
oh my
Ethan
Dan what is going on
Ethan get me a soda
oh goodness
did he actually is he actually going
through a drive-through right now
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I gotta show
your dad this is too much
you are too
and can I get like uh three
uh normal cheeseburgers and then that's
all
okay thank you
my friend said he's watching this right
now he's watching us or something
Erie yeah he's been watching since the
beginning of oh I didn't know anything
and his mom all he says is Ethan and his
mom and me are on right now
did everyone hear everything I was
saying or was I muted oh my God no we've
we've been live oh wow
Ethan sometimes does this oh he leaves
and he takes a long time oh my God and I
was ranting and going on and on and on
people are loving you they've been
loving it yeah oh I've been telling all
my Hollywood stories huh oh no Barbie
wow okay as long as everyone was liking
him
yes sweetheart wanna see my dog my
beautiful dog oh here's Blake Rosie
you're calling me
hi Angel
Ethan's a goofball hello hey Blake
I'm sorry about that I'm on a podcast
right now live you know to like 30 000
people and I can't I'm right now I'm
thinking more like 4 30 I hope that
won't hurt things uh if that's the best
I can do
okay
okay I sure will thank you so much okay
see you then
show tonight
oh yeah I will you say you're doing very
well oh okay bye
okay let's see what it was going
my Rosie
oh well what'd you say he was uh you
were doing after this yeah it's a a show
that is going to be like a one-man show
at the uh yard theater and they're gonna
film it and it's uh with Blake Rosie or
I guess he does like he hires people off
of uh Craigslist to be an actor to be
like in a one-man show that they put
together within like four hours but it's
not a uh so he says talk about the show
while you're on the podcast but I he
didn't tell me the name of the show I
guess he it's called Blake Rosier shows
yeah and then my other friend says he's
been watching it and uh Austin from
Boston is out there uh shout out to
Austin from Boston he's watching the
show he was on previously with us and uh
he's um watching from home until about
50 people to watch it uh he's on Tick
Tock Austin from Boston and again my
take talk is Eddie lavezi e d d i e l o
v e s e and thanks so much for having me
on all my fans that are watching I told
you to to watch the H3 podcast and then
they do watch it religiously every day
and they're happy that I'm on here and I
really uh I'm so grateful to Ethan for
bringing me on
and it's nice to meet his mom and she
has other fans and Chad loves you Eddie
everyone loves you oh thank you Chad
keep chatting keep uh bringing in those
beautiful comments we love you back and
uh and Ethan is so proud to have this
going on and uh all the support you give
us is really appreciated
and we all love you and the crew here is
just beautiful it's so nice to see each
other here and I love you all the great
people we love you we love you I love
listening to all your stories oh thanks
I went on to do tangents thinking we
weren't really like filming live but uh
yeah I just wanted on and on
there have been so many happy stories
but uh it's good to be on camera again
you know in a live studio yeah my last
things were like I did a lot of
uh different uh things
that were filmed where there were fun
yeah but I don't know if you want me to
mention their name but I did some
darman's
yeah really yeah I did a lot of dorm
injury recently where I like played a
casting director and I told one guy like
you're not up to Snuff with your acting
uh come back when you know how to act or
something like that and they liked and
they go like Eddie we wish we had the
ammo the sound uh at that moment when
you said that or something but it was
MOS at the time or something and then
but I did several of their uh Darman
videos uh for YouTube recently not too
many can I
I hope this isn't too much to ask but
did they what was the pay like there
yeah they uh will pay like 16 an hour
for the not for regular uh background
work with them but if you're are 30 an
hour if you're featured so like
sometimes they'll do it doesn't sound
bad theaters you know there was a big
controversy about him underpaying his
actors yeah see all that yeah I just see
I haven't seen that but okay yeah I
guess they do you know but they get
experience and exposure and it seems
like uh they have a great time with
their directors were and their directors
are you know easy breezy and fast-paced
and it seems like there's a good guy I
put some comments in there about how
they don't serve the meals properly you
know like they need better meals they
only give you like a cold box lunch that
sometimes and they're these small little
boxes like that they get from you know
somewhere and they're like cold and
they'll only give like the principles
the lunch and sometimes the extras don't
even get lunch but some but then I after
I put the comment in their little
suggestion box then all the extras have
been starting to get fed but we did like
some boxing scenes in a boxing you know
place and you remember the name of the
video I don't but my friend has a whole
list of the ones I've been in and and I
haven't even seen them I don't even
watched I hadn't even watched them but I
will and once I do I'll get you the list
of all the ones I've been in yeah we got
to see your cameo but I've did those you
know off the side just because when
you're waiting around for the union
background extra work or when you're
trying to you know find gigs I want to
add something yeah if Ethan gonna bring
me some McDonald's
or when they call you because you're in
Burbank and it's five minutes away from
where you live it's so convenient to
like just go over to that darling I
cannot believe your son Gary
is Gary there it was Gary to say about
this
I think he's you're taking the dogs for
a walk
well take your time Eddie what was your
favorite set to work on oh yeah probably
uh well Back to the Future Part Two and
uh Christmas Vacation were fun sets yeah
I did 50 scenes we recreated all the
chicken of the sea Dance you know from
the from the uh the original locations
and and when you're working on like you
know I well I did a Leo DiCaprio's
movies you know those are fun to work on
and the uh and sets you know and you
know when they recreate like you know
when we did yes man with Jim Carrey they
recreated like a an actual bar from Los
Feliz inside Warner Brothers or you know
like when you work on
different sets that they have to
recreate you know restaurants or
business or company oh and then I did
Chippendales movies recently a TV show
Chippendales that was fun to work
McNuggets and root beer yeah you got it
gave I'm gonna get it for you after the
episode I'll run that over to you buddy
and we had to like do like the 70s you
know uh Chippendales like discos or you
know like when you get to work with like
uh you know different actors that are uh
kind of controversial and then they're
working in uh and you recreate like
Teddy bar scenes or you know like strip
clubs striptease clubs those are
interesting to work in because you know
you get like dance the dancing on the
poles and the and all that and they have
to like you have to like really get into
it and like throw them some money and
they do lap dances around you or on top
of you and and you can't say no you have
to do it and then well I did work on a
fun set too recently was uh when I did
that Grace and Frankie you know with uh
you know and you would think that like
Jane Fonda would be like standoffish and
kind of snotty or you know like kind of
uppity but instead she smiles at you or
you know she knows that you kind of know
feel for her type of acting and so you
get that kind of exchange eye contact
where normally actresses don't do that
sometimes or they don't want you in
their eye line
but like with Jane Fonda she kind of
looked at me like uh you know it was a
thrill to work with her on the set and
well a lot of people who worked on the
prom like the the sets from The Prom
movie because it was a musical and they
put all the actual like Meryl Streep as
you know dancing around right next to
you and singing and so those are fun to
work on you know when you're like and
they recreate like you know New York
sets or things like that
but a lot of times too when you're uh
when you're doing uh
you know period pieces those are fun you
know I had to do a lot of one where I
was in that um you know period piece in
the 20s or 30s and you have to wear like
really thick wool clothes in the middle
of summer oh and the fun one I did was I
played a redneck in the crisp in uh that
movie about the uh Santa Clauses it was
about like you know with uh you know the
guy from uh yeah Home Improvement
Yeah Tim Allen and he played the Santa
Claus and then we had to be like
redville like uh we had to be like
people in like a country town and so we
had to wear overalls and like be like
all country you know in a country like
Carnival and those are fun to work on
and then like I did one with like one of
the uh where you know you had to work at
night and they put a lot of like you
know fog or you know like a lot of um
maybe you're pretending that it's like
you know kind of a Renaissance feel and
so you have people on horses or the star
on a horse and you have to like be like
people that um that are in that town
like it's sort of like if you're like
you know in that
in that you know like kind of like
Beauty and the Beast times or something
like that you know and those but then
you could be freezing cold one that I
did recently was where we did like we
had to use our phones and it was an app
on a phone and it was a you know
Courtney Cox's David Arquette Arquette
it was produced by him and it was a TV
series or a movie in which we had to
like actually like be like we were they
would they would like you know do like
the Jim Carrey from from like you know
Batman Forever type of thing where they
kind of got into your mind because you
were on a phone and and the app told you
what you had to do and so interesting
and all the people had to like Point
their camera at a dead person's body
that was on the shore of the ocean of
the and we had to work in Malibu let's
say or you know if you work in a Malibu
mansion those are fun sets to work on
when you're like in the party scenes and
you're you know a friend of mine who
looks like Sylvester Stallone he's a
younger version of Sly Stallone
um had to do like you know you had to be
like
different movies where like you know
you'll you'll get to uh
to do scenes you know where where they
might be like making you like a pool man
or pool boy or you know like
things like that I'm so curious about
Wizards of Waverly Place because that
was my favorite show Growing Up yeah
that was fun to work on those great
sitcoms you know that are uh they're
very good and you know they have a lot
of uh
oh yeah not I did a lot of the iCarly's
and the Really and all those Nickelodeon
shows you know like iCarly or uh
different shows like that uh and uh I
was in some episodes where like I'm
featured like in a wedding scene or
different uh things like on the nanny I
was swabbing the deck in like a Titanic
Recreation scene uh or you know you
might be like in a scene with Joan
Collins you know and that you you know
or fun scenes like that because they
always brought in guest stars on on The
Nanny and I worked on that a few several
times and then Melrose plays 90210 I
proposed to Tori Spelling a 90210 and
she said yes and
but uh yeah working on Melrose plays
with like you know Heather Dean Locklear
and location scenes and then also they
filmed a lot of the scenes inside of the
Santa Clarita Studios or uh recently uh
yeah let me pull up some of the ones
that I've done recently and I could tell
you more you know oh
they got me on uh a show that's all
vaxed for tomorrow I'm supposed to be on
MasterChef oh so I have to confirm it's
uh it's one of those cooking shows but I
haven't been on that in a while is he
your book does audience I'm the all-vac
show MasterChef test work tomorrow
please let us know if you're a fan of
the show and what have you seen some
episodes
so I have you wanted to have a great day
blah blah blah
um MasterChef for tomorrow
so but I'll pull up some of the ones
that I've done recently then you'll like
the ones that I've done let's see now
that we have a minute hey Ethan's back
all right
not yet no thank you though appreciate
it
I'm good thank you very much
Ethan I thought you're on a diet why are
you eating that stuff what
I can't believe you went through a
drive-thru
I
I trust Eddie
ultimately oh thank you so much yeah the
thing is
I went to the bathroom uh-huh
and you started ripping oh yeah and I
was I was captivated oh so was the
audience oh wow and so that's so
interesting wow thank you for doing that
I appreciate it
was that whole time that was amazing the
hair I thought it was just talking to
the crew no it was live the whole time
but it was so interesting thank you you
have so much inside information oh yeah
well you know it's been a pleasure
working with you here and being in the
studio with you it's so much fun it is
it's incredible thank you so much and by
the way yeah oh you guys want some
McDonald's I got like I got so much for
everybody just come help yourselves
thank you I got crispy chickens if
someone doesn't want I got like a ton of
nuggets are you sure you don't like
McDonald's oh no thank you thank you
though yeah I'm on that field grade
system where you have to drink something
10 minutes before you're gonna eat so
it'll burn feel great fiber you know in
the foods what's the field rate it's
like a nutritional supplement drink so
that you can um
get fiber and Matrix in your foods and
not have a you you fast every day like
Yom Kippur for all the Yom kippurs that
I didn't fast enough yeah
yeah lost 33 pounds in like six weeks
and Counting you know in inches off my
belly fat and hoping to reverse my type
2 diabetes oh sure I'll be on Glipizide
metformin oh sure so I haven't had
anything good for you yeah thanks I was
just getting to a list of the things I'd
worked on why men can jump the new
reboot TV series winning time let's see
Walmart commercial weird oh I did the
Weird Al movie where I played like in a
bathroom scene with Al Yankovic played
by Harry Potter you know Daniel
Radcliffe and I was in the terminal list
and the mass singer a lot and the Lakers
project and the choices we make and
Euphoria that's my jam super pumped was
a movie about Uber it was uh with the
guy from Third Rock From the Sun super
pumped and I did redville and rap [__]
recently in the pool man with you know
Chris Pine and on my block was one about
like uh where you were like in the Baha
in uh Lonely Planet like I love this for
you Harry Potter Grace and Frankie
Euphoria and Lizzie Curb Your Enthusiasm
dead to me Chippendales uh bromates
broch spin-off I did a lot of people saw
me a lot in that
Barry the TV series they saw me a lot in
Berry and Arnold's was like a Caribbean
sitcom with all black cast and they like
me and that and featured me a lot in
that that was done in like Woodland
Hills where your mom lives and we had to
go to like a studio with like a small
little studio in Woodland Hills for
Arnold's it was about Caribbean like uh
sitcom with uh black they had to have
very thick Caribbean accents from
Jamaica man and they come on and the oh
there was 15 ahr was like 15 aora it was
a Mexican sitcom called 15 aora and it
was I worked on that
recently and that was in I need a water
yeah I've got one right here thanks it
was in MacArthur Park where I I mean we
had to like feed the pig be like people
in the park
thanks
would you ever go for a main role or are
you like
married to the extra yeah I have done
some main roles you know but when you're
as a an extra you get Thrones like
featured in speaking right there on the
set oh really
by the way we followed you Eddie oh my
God thank you thank you oh this is a
real thrill thank you so much because I
know you only follow like 13 people
right now one of them where do you want
people to follow you oh on Eddie lovesi
at Tick Tock Eddie
l-o-v-e-s-e Eddie lovese because when I
was going to be Eddie loves something
that Tick Tock only lets you have a
certain amount of words so that's why it
had to be Eddie Levesque because Tick
Tock kind of cut off one or two words
Instagram or anything else no just just
touch that just Tick Tock Eddie lovese e
d d i e l o v e s e thank you Eddie
lovese on Tick Tock
thank you
oh it's an honor for you to follow me
back and I'm going to promote the heck
the hell out of you guys uh and you
already have promotion but you know
every day I'm going to mention you
constantly we're allergic Subs so yeah
we can use all the help let's bring you
up buddy you were saying you worked with
um Darman yeah did you ever feel
exploited by him I didn't really because
you know they've got good fast directors
and the scenes were done quick and you
know it seemed like they're learning and
they're teaching and they have I like
the fact that they had actors that were
there that probably don't get enough
exposure or work or you know they're
good enough and they seem to be good and
yet they uh they're not too mean to them
and they don't tell them they can't act
they just let them be who they are and
it seemed like he was it's a nice
environment to work did you do long days
there not too long no you know six eight
hour days nothing too long because they
don't want too much overtime of course
but but still you know I like the in and
out because then you can kind of have
the rest of your day free or good
locations although you know he should
pay actors more but hey you know I'm
sure you had to pay a lot for the
putting two big studios together and
putting all Interiors inside the studio
a lot he had to put a lot of Interiors
so you know that costs a lot and then to
for today's after the pandemic it's hard
to get a thing going you know something
I let him be I have to say I'm utterly
impressed with your ability to riff oh
thanks I just go home that was
incredible though oh my gosh I think you
went for 30. oh not a single question
well I get my inspiration through you
because you're so brilliant that it came
off of you that whole via the energy and
you really are you really are the man
Everybody follow shirtless Eddie thank
you Eddie on Tick Tock y'all I love you
well what we should do now is hey Mom
are you there yeah I'm still here okay
so everybody's waiting for the yeah
for the Haley Bieber I'm gonna stop
eating now guys don't worry
um
let me finish this mouthful and then
I'll move on
everybody's wanting to know Mom what is
the drama between
uh Haley Bieber and Selena Gomez have
you been looking into it
I familiarized myself with everything
about them
so do you want me to talk about it
seriously I have no idea I think Eddie
has some grasp on it but I myself am and
all of us here are fairly confused so
I mean yeah what happened I mean
ultimately tell us well the first thing
I did was look into the background and
how they know each other
and
um uh basically Selena Gomez and Taylor
Swift and Justin Bieber are all talents
little talents you know
um
debatable am I right Eddie all right
Ethan
no but I know what I mean you know
Taylor's Taylor Swift started she was
really young and
um she signed with
um Sony I think she was only 14 years
old wow and and
um and then Justin Bieber you know he
was discovered on YouTube right uh and
then
um Selena Gomez she was really young she
started with Barney and Friends and then
went on in her young teens on the Disney
Channel wow okay so they're all kind of
child stars if you if you would they are
they're all musically fine and and then
on the other side of the spectrum you've
got
his of famous people
you know you've got the Kylie Jenner and
you've uh uh uh what's her name the
Kendall Jenner and you've got Haley who
is you're speaking about Baldwin Alex
and so what's interesting is we're
almost talking about like people that
made it from their own Merit versus nepo
babies as we call them yes I'd say
that's pretty much now Mom would you
consider me a nepo baby
no right how could that be I mean well
some people say my my
um biological Grandpa was a great film
producer
yeah but you never even met him okay
right yeah come on they didn't know you
from Adam okay so I'm more I'd be more
in the camp with someone like Justin
Bieber
yes yes you're a self-made man thank you
so much for saying that my mom
as Justin Bieber was discovered and
although he's very talented and he put
himself out on YouTube hoping
by networking he would be discovered and
he's rebelled and he was discovered okay
and uh Taylor Swift I mean they were all
young
Roger progenies they
um they were incredibly and put
themselves out there and were discovered
and Selena Gomez you know she what she
did acting and then was on the Disney
Channel and she's got some chops so
where does so where so we have these
famous Bunch where does the conflicts
come in well
um it seems that
Haley
um
Baldwin at the time
in a very young age
um her her dad is stupid Baldwin who is
a real kind of a religious really
religious Off the Wall kind of guy right
and here too
um
neighbor's con concerts because she was
a big fan and because of who he is she
was able to get backstage beat him and
she went on
um she went to two of his concerts and I
apparently they befriended each other
you know life goes to like and and to be
perfectly honest Ethan I think you kind
of know this when you become famous you
kind of are a little secluded
and and you know the the whole social
media thing now is completely different
than you know a few years ago where you
could reach out to someone you know like
um
you know you could send someone a direct
message and say hey I'm so and so I
admire your work and and then you kind
of me become friends you know so
um there's that and
um I just think that when you're
especially young you you kind of I mean
other than your family it's really hard
to just be a regular person
what do you think Eddie uh your laughter
Oh
yes I
said she's got she's got it she's
retailed it nailed it yeah so okay but
but so Justin Bieber and Haley they're
married well we know about that so what
is the state
um Selena
on and off for eight years you know they
were young and uh there was a little bit
of drugs going on and drugs
yeah they were they both got into
um
well I don't know if she was but best in
people yeah what kind of stuff were they
getting into yeah
but her team claimed it was for mental
yeah okay okay interesting I believe no
I mean it's all alleged but that's what
I looked into and and read and you know
Justin Bieber is was a young boy and you
know young and dumb he probably did some
really stupid things and they were on
and off dating and you know
um it's really hard for a young man to
just go ahead and and meet someone as a
matter of fact he met Selena through his
um his manager I guess you know they
were introduced by
um
let's cut let's cut to the chase a
little bit so the conflict
well the conflict it's the whole thing
is so uh convoluted right it was a
eyebrows if you oh okay so whose
eyebrows
Selena Gomez was kind of fun of herself
and put out
um I don't know if it was on Instagram I
think it would Instagram or Tick Tock
one of those I think I had a bit
Instagram and she had eyes
accepting young girls
and she put a picture of herself with
Goofy eyebrows and Haley uh Bieber and
and Kylie Jenner I mean the two of them
are are friends you know they they Kylie
let's see I guess it was
they how do they know each other uh
they Mom I'm more confused than ever I
have to be honest
I I don't know what's happening okay
well the thing is all of these people
employ each other in my tail Quest yeah
it is is Selena's very very close friend
okay
and she used to be friends with with
Kendall Jenner okay you know full circle
of friends and they kind of broke up
friendships boys did someone dating I
mean Taylor Swift I'm a team I'm a
Swifty and a gomezzy
personally I'm I ride for the salinator
wait can you can you factor me on that
Ian you were saying it earlier a
salinator yeah
yes okay but so so where's the okay so
Selena posted an eyebrow pic do we have
the eyebrow pick okay so let me shade
the eyebrow pick so this is what started
it all
Selena being her uh fun-loving confident
queen self
posted this
he was goofing on herself where she
posted
so a picture of her eyes
she painted it on is that what it is so
at the beginning of that video she says
I accidentally laminated my eyebrows too
much okay yeah
Donna is completely
my name is so right here
that's okay okay so then she put out
this video
you following Eddie yes okay
here's the tick tock is this the tick
tock that Haley Bieber put out making
fun of her yeah okay so let's watch this
now
okay it was Haley yeah
so
so what the [__] did I just watch how
was that how was that about Selena
well hold on hold on hold on what the
hell how are they okay this is where I'm
having trouble
okay so here is her his now wife Haley
holding up a picture about Justin and
Selena's breakup
soon as Justin Bieber broke up with with
Lena it was a very short time that he
start being uh Kylie and they ended up
getting engaged and then Kylie
I think I'm sorry Haley okay started
daily dating Haley you know she met him
years ago backstage but I know I'm still
trying to understand where's what's like
so offensive about this video
could jump in Olivia yeah okay so what
had happened at the beginning of this
year was Selena Gomez was being highly
scrutinized for her weight gain which
she has since she doesn't need to
explain herself but she has since gone
on to explain that her lupus medication
makes her gain weight
um so a lot of people took this video
which included Kendall Jenner who many
speculate Justin cheated on Selena with
Haley who also Justin allegedly cheated
on Selena with but she denies it and
this girl I I included um a screenshot
of her Snapchat story in May 2022
she had posted a photo the girl on the
right she's a singer she had posted a
photo with Haley and then right
afterward she posted um a text post that
was clearly shading Selena Gomez that
said
um
let me so why are they being so mean
girls well that's the thing is people
are like what's happening right now well
the reason why okay why because Taylor
Swift and and Selena are are really
close friends they met each other
because they were both dating
um Brothers they were both dating oh who
were the brothers
[Music]
scooter no no no no wait let me think
the Jonas Brothers
who's scooter
how does scooter get involved now I'm
just confused someone's on a scooter no
Scooter Braun is the one who
got discovered Justin Bieber what did
scooter to do with it
there's nothing to do with it oh okay
just discovered
um
uh Justin Bieber with Asher
Asher who's Asher oh sure
so basically
um Tyler dated
um what was his name Harry Style
and and also their friend Jack Kendall
Kendall Jenners who used to be friends
with Taylor the two of them made a girl
Pat they would never date each other's
friends and she found at the Kendall
Jenner dated and dated him for a long
time Harry I'm so confused I'm getting
more confused
and poor Selena is kind of stuck with
people picking on her because she was
sticking up for her friend Taylor and
you know basically she's had a weight
problem because she takes medication for
her lupus and and lately it's it's
allegedly that uh
um Justin Bieber has been following her
and doesn't want to let her go out of
his life Selena
yes oh Justin saw his interest in Selena
do you think well allegedly she was the
one that got away fans speculate oh
that's and so but okay let me watch this
again the thing that really started
what so what are they saying she
deserved if this is to her what are they
saying she deserved people speculated
that that was about people being mean
about her weight gain
so she's there's people think they're
saying she deserves to be bullied well
here's the sich is if it were just that
I would have been like
but with all of the compelling evidence
that um there is I think that they're
shading each other online okay yeah I
mean the whole thing is so it's so it's
such High School drama yeah really
really
such girly High School drama and it's a
big circle of imagine yourself in high
school and all the cool kids are friends
and then suddenly one girl starts dating
the other girl's boyfriend and it's it's
really ridiculous and and on social
media you know it's right out there for
everyone to see and you know when when
Selena was just being goofy on herself
they took the opportunity to make fun of
her and the fans you know people they
like uh Selena Gomez
okay so here's the here's the other girl
that was in the shot no that's oh yeah
yeah so she says
she said this was in May of 2022. why do
they hate Selena what did she do she
because it was a long time
that's it was her crime is loving Justin
Bieber then we're all guilty
it's all about
C and then the worst part was when
Taylor Swift won that award
and Kylie Jenner's brother-in-law you
know Mr Mr uh Kanye got up there and
dissed Taylor Swift
um as she was trying to accept her award
right well so so because he's married to
Kim and Kim his sisters with Kylie and
that this is this is complicated stuff
very incestors very Game of Thrones
really really it is Gabe what are your
thoughts on this do you have an opinion
about
Selena Gomez Gabe
games
Gabe doesn't have an opinion and that's
that's honestly the right approach
because who knows what's going on but
thank you good
um let's see Selena Gomez left a comment
that said it's okay I don't let these
things get me down be nice to everyone
so she's a queen that's Rising above is
that right
yeah I mean it's kind of off of the
social media for a while to just calm
things down it's like it's ridiculous
she made a comment look at I'm 30 years
old I want to get through this this is
really silliness and you know so like
Kendall Zone Kendall's 27 and uh I think
Kylie's 25 but they're acting like
they're you know like they're being 17
year old girls also like okay okay and
then Haley Bieber Who's now
she says I never comment on this type of
thing but we were just having a girls
night out and did a random Tick Tock
sound for fun it's not direct anyone we
don't believe that do we
um yeah you believe me no no however
halif and Justin fans are using and I
will say that I think Selena definitely
stoked a fire if there was one then
rightfully so if not he kind of started
something by leaving a public comment on
a re-upload of that well clearly she
felt okay so she commented on a
re-upload because Haley deleted that
Tick Tock as soon as it got Mass hate
clearly she felt under attack yeah and
to be honest as a Selena fan I totally
stand by that what are your thoughts on
that uh mom or uh
I have kids so I get confused I'm
adorable my wife is Mom now yeah
I know I never know if it's Grandma or
Mom it's it's hard to figure that one
out sometimes but anyways I think Selena
made a comment because they were
attacking Taylor Swift and she was her
friend oh so what did they say about
Taylor Swift because I didn't even know
well you know she's on I guess it's is
it is it uh Kendall that's on that show
where they they dance to music and do
crazy stunts oh here's Haley Throwing
Shade
this is all complicated it's so
convoluted the whole thing is Goofy
Selena so Tick Tock of Haley's
simulating gagging where's that one I'm
trying to think but nothing so here's
when they were talking about Taylor
Swift's music you know yeah
that I was nutso to like Taylor Swift
this was like when she just became
popular and I've always liked that young
music I think she's very talented and I
that she was jealous to be a fan of
Taylor Swift oh not really not
particularly
but I know she's really a good writer
and she's done a great job it's not your
cup of tea yeah yeah yeah got you yeah
be careful
and BTS oh yeah they're great
good good
and to be honest I think because it's
it's very childish that these girls have
a circle of friends and I think maybe uh
Kylie felt like she was being left out
of the circle of friendship and maybe
she got jealous so here here's another
receipt
this says and that's the comments Selena
left on it okay this has got it all so
Selena said so sorry my best friend is
and continues to be one of the best in
the game talking about Taylor that Haley
BB Haley BB is on some kind of award
show this is this clip is a few years
old
but it was going viral and Selena left
this comment last week okay yes so let's
see what she says friend is that Method
Man how is Method Man involved in all
this
do we know that's the woo connection do
we know Method Man stance is he Selena
or Bieber
I think he's just the host he's hosted
that show where they play songs and I
think they do like karaoke and do
weird things do you not think it's
significant he's standing next to her
when she disses Gomez well he can't help
it and he's standing next not a co-sign
post and she he can't control what she
says this isn't exactly what I think of
when I think of Street beef kind of if
you think about old school like Wu-Tang
kind of gang violence this doesn't
really rise to that do you think
no no it seems a little more like
not as serious but let's see full of the
meanest lyrics about a celebrity since
Taylor Swift's last album
okay why that is so catty and mean and
rude like who are you by the way what
have you ever done with your life Haley
except you're the daughter of someone
famous
in your life you're talking about Taylor
Swift who built an Empire from being a
musical genius who are you oh you were
pretty oh you cool just because you've
just because you [__] Justin Bieber
doesn't mean you absorb his talent
well she's a model
a little industry if she wasn't famous
yeah no one has a problem with Haley
Bieber until she's mean she's a mean
maybe don't be mean I don't like her
what are your thoughts on Haley no I
don't like her we don't like her she's
just so catty and me for what for what
you're gonna be a dick at least have
some credentials she has her own
smoothie it really wasn't good something
how much was it 15 bucks I think
probably a good deal
good deal compared to what I've seen um
if you're going to talk about the
eyebrows this is the time okay now we're
getting to the eyebrows because this is
really
this is heavy duty stuff man
yeah Method Man took one look at this
and said this is who's dangerous for me
to get involved in
okay so then we've got moving on we're
saying
Celine had posted a video
okay
so here's another video of her eyebrows
after she waxed them
it just seems like such an innocent
nothing video sounds like
she was
just an honors no this wasn't her
attacking anyone any this was she posted
this and then Kylie Jenner and Haley
Bieber seemingly mocked her right so she
posted this this was an accident how do
you know that she's talking about her
okay
go down
so what the [__] is this Selena had just
posted I accidentally laminated my
eyebrows too much shorts like what are
they saying that are eyebrows look ugly
who really cares but it looks like
they're saying we're watching you and
we're mocking you what do you really am
I delusional well what is she saying
this was an accident like I don't
understand and then the text is on her
eyebrow
and then the next one to be very clear
she tagged Haley Bieber that they were
talking with one other one another
costumed in her eyebrows
why would they do that that's so weird
right and also just the fact that Selena
said I accidentally laminated my
eyebrows and she's like this was an
accident
it's a little it's a little
Shady yeah right
also something Kylie Jenner what's the
what what have you done except that
[__] Pepsi commercial that like
should have ruined your career don't get
me started on those two you remember
that Pepsi yes I do unbelievable get
your [__] ass up and work yes right
so so far Mom are we accurate I think so
I mean you know what you can
uh Haley uh Baldwin and her sister
Kendall they're both models they're
pretty girls you know but would they
have gotten their foot in the door if
they were just anybody because there's
so many beautiful women of course you
know I mean
um I know that there's like um Cindy
Crawford's daughter you know she is a
beautiful mother she looks just like her
mom did she knows how is Cindy
Crawford's daughter involved
no she's not I'm just saying Justin
Bieber or Jim wait is she team Bieber or
team Gomez
no I'm just I have no idea Ethan I'm
just saying you don't know I thought you
were doing research her mother is a
famous model but in truth be told she
looks exactly like Cindy Crawford and
the girls got her walked down and she's
just you know you could see where
someone like her would become a model on
her so she's team Gomez I assuming she's
team or she'll be team Beaver because
she's a nepo she's nepotism Maybe
right is my logic sound there that's
okay good good well I don't know do you
need to head out it's four o'clock
okay okay thank you Eddie why would I
leave this yeah yeah yes of course
shirtless
all right to be honest with you guys I'm
this is Kylie Jenner now she says this
is reaching no shade swords Selena ever
and I didn't see your eyebrows to post
you guys are making something silly out
of nothing hmm really
Selena said agreed it's all unnecessary
I'm a fan of Kylie
what do we think about that I think
that's her saying she's just a fan of
Kylie
what do we do about it
so Kylie's not involved
well Kylie did post that I think Kylie
was the instigator if you if you ask me
yeah
I think Haley probably wouldn't have
posted anything but Kylie was really an
instigator interesting I don't know the
whole thing is just silly The Fallout
was crazy because Haley Bieber lost
Millions on Instagram
and Gomez gained Millions on Instagram
so clearly some people understand what's
going on enough
if you look at old videos which you know
you had me research this so I looked up
everything
um when Selena Gomez was dating Justin
Bieber when when you know when they were
a hardcore couple you see pictures of
her with his family and interviews with
Bieber's mother and they all really
liked her she was a very sweet girl you
can see how that she interacted with the
younger siblings and then you know uh
fast forward to uh Kylie uh Baldwin and
you could just see she's a little
you know
uh full of herself kind of rich girl
attitude and it's she's a different kind
of girl I just thought of something tons
of money you know I have to chime in
here I've thought of something you know
with with benefit happening and you know
Ben Affleck and JLo getting back
together after all those years yeah
benefit I think that's probably the
reason uh Haley Bieber is just worried
that you know there'll be a relapse with
Justin Bieber getting back with Selena's
story yes because of benefits
they just want to act like that that you
know maybe and also it's probably an
open relationship you know there are
three you think they're doing keeping it
they're doing a throttle he's still with
Selena he's doing
they've been blinking they've been now
that explains doing it for a few years
now and so Haley's just in on the joke
she's in on it she likes that they're
not happy
that makes everybody happier so now now
what does this mean she posted this is I
guess uh Haley's Instagram story I have
no idea what this me is or why it's
significant
um this that photo of them together was
a few months ago that
went viral everyone was like oh they
pose together okay that's just the cover
photo but this morning Haley posted she
reposted someone's story and right now
there's a famous song called calm down
which is by remma but the one that's
going that is like number one is the one
the remix with Selena Gomez and Haley
reposted someone's story using the remna
song without the Selena Gomez JD that is
a shady caddy I thought it was shady I
do not like Haley yeah I'm gonna put
that out there
before this I did I didn't have a
problem I don't like it but I don't like
I don't like when people are mean and
now they've bullied Selena and she's on
a social media break so congratulations
Mean Girls you got your wish right mom
did we get that right I I think he's
probably back now but you know what
I think that the fans are good judge of
character and they can see who is who's
being nice and who's not being nice and
who's being childish you know
let's face it but you go to school
there's always those the The Click you
know and then they they pick on because
they think they're better than other
kids you know and that's pretty much
what's going on I just think that Kylie
Jenner isn't in The Clique with with
Taylor Swift and Selena for a number of
reasons and
um okay Gabe what's your assessment here
games
I have no clue yeah I'm kind of there
with you buddy if I was mapping I
probably would understand this better
all right mom well well there you go
there's my mom uh she is
thank you for giving us all your time my
mom's on Cameo by the way
she's very lovely and she looks so young
and no wonder you didn't call her a
grandmother because you know she doesn't
look like at all she looks like a young
45 year old this is a good guy right
here huh she looks my age yeah
37 37. you're looking about 29. thank
you so much Eddie I love you I love you
back you look about uh
I'm against your age yeah I would say I
don't know 32. wow thank you so much
well you know I appreciate that yeah
yeah I was on this one game show one
time called The Age game where they had
to guess our ages you know and
everything and that's always been uh
that was fun
how long ago was that it was recently A
couple of years ago one of the warm-up
guys from one of the game shows you know
was uh producing it or trying to get a
new game show off the ground you know
from the people that do brought you the
mass singer or the singing uh there was
another show after the mass singer in
which they were trying to like he was a
part of and then he uh had me go over to
this do run show Run game shows run
throughs
and it was fun we got to like had to uh
the people had to you know play game
guessing games
so so how old did they think you were
yeah I think at that time like 38 39 40
something you know so they got it right
yeah yeah oh pretty good guess very good
guesses now hey you guys you all want to
stick around for the next story mom and
Gabe you guys want to stay on the phone
[Applause]
um
you have to practice something
yeah what does that mean okay I'll stay
on the phone with you I'll Stand
bail what do you have to practice what
do you do
well I was I was practicing my Mahjong
uh with my she's got something important
to do you gotta practice Mahjong that is
important who are we
[Laughter]
hey Mom you want to plug your cameo Hey
listen
well the show was it was under control
and yeah no I was able he needs a little
free time to get out there and see the
world and you know like they say uh you
enjoy the breeze you know and like
that's right because it's raining and it
never rains in L.A hardly never so when
you dance you want to smell that fresh
air that's not so polluted ain't that
the truth and get out there that's right
yes
I'm sitting at in the office and I have
a picture of you and John and myself can
I show your fans but you
okay
let's see this is my boys
look at look at how look at how young
they are
we were in Mexico
weren't we I think there was a Cabo
very uh very cute very handsome and a
handsome family very he gets good genes
from you very nice
you have amazing skin good eyebrows do
you um do you do you put on sunscreen I
do every day
it's so beautiful thank you
I had a feeling yes I had a feeling
well
uh should I stay or should I go should I
stay or should I go
sure that's a song You're I really I
love that because everything she says is
another song from a popular right or
should I go right
we should stay you should stay we know
it's a great time here we're having a
wonderful time and when do you get to
see your handsome son all the time
you know that episode of Seinfeld where
his parents get sick of him oh yeah yeah
that's my parents
true
that's not true I love my beautiful
Grandsons too and my beautiful daughter
oh they're really good looking yeah good
looking kids
um do you want to plug your cameo mom
oh uh sure I'm on Cameo and I love
hearing from all of your fans actually
it's it's a it's a really great
experience
and your fans are
um smart and uh talented and I'm always
Blown Away
um by what they do and what they say and
um it's been fun so
that there you have it
[Applause]
you should be on Camp no you wouldn't
have enough time to be on cameo
Ethan
hmm
want to see a picture of your sister
let's talk about something
okay
um
we might be out of time though here guys
actually it's getting pretty late oh
we're having such a great time how long
we've been going Dan
and you have uh two hours and 45 minutes
I like your socks and your espadrilles
thank you so much you notice what I'm
wearing shorts shorts nice shorts no
shorts thank you love it Teddy fresh
yeah
it's nice and toasty because it's so
bloody cold outside
uh what do you think about this fresh
and fit don't want women to wear makeup
you can what makes me sick oh wait this
isn't fresh and fit this is some
wannabes
um
bro imagine being a knock off a fresh
and fit
is Wednesday shots these men are a
Cancer in society like what is happening
what makes me say that yeah what makes
you think okay two things
filters and makeup
makeup's lying makeup is the most except
accepted lie in society
also like dyeing your hair an unnatural
color is blind I suppose it is yes okay
I don't understand why are you so
offended it's like you're lying to me
shut up dude
you just wish your ugly ass could
[__] cover your face
and we all do too let's cover his face
right right thank you right Mom
men can grow beards and and hide that's
a lie oh beards are the biggest lion
Society
here
that's what my mom brings a good point
if makeup is alive yeah and so oh it's
an incredible point I see it's just
coverage your whole black right right
right right right yeah that's actually
great anyone else's Eliza's fake leather
jacket that he got from TJ Maxx that's
definitely okay
you know what else is a lie hair
color most of your head just take it all
that's why I'm the most honest man in
Show Business
that's also changing your appearance
that's not that's not a lie though
that's look how much you're covering
your face you insecure loser dude this
guy's covering like
thirty percent of his face easily easily
easily that's a lie stop lying to me God
knows what's underneath that beard right
they could it's probably a um
a virgin chin literally lying
you're you're actually making it you're
accentuating your body you're conflating
exercising and getting fit to
make up something that can be put on and
removed couldn't you compare your beard
to makeup since it hides
there you are queen
no not really that's definitely
different why
how is it different dude he just got
yeah what do we think pretty good he's
gonna have it like
it does take it off it's gonna grow back
it's a part of him whereas like we
choose when we want to put on and take
off makeup oh so are these the Judas the
women who are gender Traders
yeah yeah every man needs a every evil
man needs a jizzling you know
I mean but like you can choose and when
you want to take off it's changing your
appearance right it's totally different
though why because you Contour your face
a certain way whereas you can't tell
your beard to grow a certain way well
you can shape it a certain way yeah you
can shave it like this is really uh
compelling stuff here also their audio
consistency is dog [__] yeah and then
the paper cups the paper cups could they
get like better like palaces or upgrade
yeah
it's nicer I need a [__] I need some
kind of chicken that looks cheesy with
the paper cups absolutely it's so low
it's so low budget
at least you have glasses and you have a
nice water bottle thank you and you know
what it's like his podcast is whatever I
get it that's what I think when I watch
it whatever
have a good night
during haircuts or like
um like beard shaping just to like get a
certain defined um her mic's not even on
might not it's not even on so you're
comparing a beard to makeup
um yes yes dude you have no rebuttal so
you just repeated their point they
already said it like three times bro you
are defenseless you just took the L
whatever bro tap dance on his grave
right Eddie right sir that's right what
should we do to him
oh make him shave his beard or uh like
say uh maybe uh paint uh get a one of
those uh things where you change it the
way he looks on the camera or something
right filter I think he's got to shave
it
not directly I'm not saying they're the
same thing I'm just saying you probably
having that beard makes you a little bit
more flattering clean in the same way
that makeup might make a woman look more
flattering
I I sort of see what you're saying
um certainly some men the the beard can
help shape the the jawline a bit he's on
the back foot from that I'm pretty sure
you just got dominated
the clip is titled she couldn't see
beyond her delusion who are you bro what
a loser loser loser that's right Eddie
we should shave off his beard and and uh
put the hair glue the hair on his
nipples or something make them hairy
nipples
right right
I'm Anne right Gabe
it was
that wore them this is this is the
[__] goddamn wishes [__] episode I
love that firm why is it set why is it
seven uh is that what um
he's got a seven pin on his hoodie what
does it mean that he
what is it his IQ
[Laughter]
the price of the price of the jacket
let's close her a lot closer a lie yeah
you know depending upon where to make
your
make your shoulders look better or are
you sure
that's so true very good point
bring it back to the original point of
you know you said that men lie about
their hide on dating apps and I said
well I think women lie more and that's
oh so they lie more I didn't know that
was the competition Who Lies more yeah
shut up
[Music]
sounds like he's moving the goal post
exactly
up and through filters so why do guys
have such an issue with makeup wouldn't
they want something that makes like
their girl or their girlfriend that look
better let's ask the chat chat let's ask
all the chauvinist women hating pigs and
chat what do you guys think
yeah that's right I'm disabled
disabled do you prefer girls without
makeup or width so with makeup without
makeup
with makeup
without making uh this guy's almost more
compelling content than we have yeah no
makeup two in the chat without makeup
one in the chat for seriously bro you
don't even have poles you don't want it
too
did they exactly copied fresh and fit
setup too the the angles the the shot
the same exactly this dude's like let's
find the worst [__] podcast and then
emulator they're not even that
successful dude
he needs to find his own version of
coconuts and Barbados
yeah he's in there she's in there kind
of I mean somebody fighting for his life
yeah you need somebody to riff with to
bounce off of like an Eddie he needs an
Eddie he needs this Rolo Tony Brown Town
yeah
yeah you were on Tim and Eric weren't
you yeah of course you were yeah good
people yeah they're really good people
yeah good for fun to work good good good
no makeup two in the chat for with or
without awesome bro super um super I'm
seeing a lot of without but this is so
stupid like you are such an idiot
what an idiot you're saying that his
audience says they prefer a woman not
wearing any makeup you know that's bull
idiot I mean yeah that's probably
[__] and also
what they think a woman not wearing
makeup is is probably still wearing
makeup you know what I mean like yeah a
lot of guys like don't even realize
what's going on with all that so
guys when they say without there's like
a no makeup makeup look that's natural
again once again
he brought him on he brought on sharks
and he's trying to spin it like he took
the dub
here's the top comment a beard just
means a man didn't shave
makeup means the person wearing it took
out the time of it seriously beard means
they didn't shave yeah maybe if you're
like look like
um maybe if you look like Tom Hanks in
Castaway right there their facial hair
stop it right right stop it
Pinocchio
he's like overtime super cakey like a
lot of eyeshadow giant lashes but like I
think just having you know even yeah
light I think it's sad that girls even
have to go on the show and like
explain themselves to this [__] pig
like
you don't have to Justify Your Existence
to these idiots you know yeah right Gabe
right
funny prizes hair
Gabe what are your thoughts you agree or
disagree
um
probably
don't agree I guess yeah yeah yeah yeah
thanks Brad
what'd you say Mom
hi blow dryer if he just you know gets
out of the shower and that's the way he
walks around oh
blow dries his hair you're so right he
puts gel in his hair for sure you're fat
you got him good
mate
beta
I'm the real Alpha
I do nothing
it's true I'm the real the real Sigma
the real Alpha Sigma right here I'm the
real deal you're looking at a real man
by your definition
I'm the most honest person in the world
love honestly say man
touches of makeup isn't something they
would prefer no I just don't realize
it's me I don't think they like notice
that that's yeah because guys can't
really tell like what what is makeup and
what's not I mean obviously if it's
really heavy on you're gonna be able to
tell but like if it's something light
and natural looking I feel like there's
no harm in that
well I mean you're certainly free to do
whatever you want but I would say
generally speaking men don't we'd
actually prefer women to not wear makeup
what who are you speaking for also like
any man who's actually like talked to
women about it
the women do it because they feel good
it's fun for them they do it for
themselves not for your dumbass [__]
bearded having leather jacket seven IQ
ass mother douche like you don't know
anything
right
and there's something weirdly like nice
guy almost like uh
you remember the guy who shot up a UCSB
Eliot Rodriguez the ultimate gentleman
there's something very nice guy about
like don't wear makeup you're beautiful
the way you are you don't have to do
anything
Elliott Rogers right you know what I
mean
don't wear makeup
don't wear nice clothes look as frumpy
as possible it's also like what do they
mean when they say you're lying you're
wearing makeup but you look better
without it what are
right what are we lying about then
what's next next thing he's gonna be
like I think you guys should actually
cover your whole bodies except for your
eyes yeah literally what
these guys are more have more in common
with Isis yeah you know what I mean
I love the high fiving
my lost boyfriend loved makeup
he wore it no he loved when I wore
makeup and that's totally fine I'm not
saying that it's the case for all men
but most men like we don't really care
what are you saying like what this man
is so dumb like you're literally so dumb
right Mom
is that a lie too
um
or perfume oh yeah I know you smell like
[__] dude take the perfume off
so true mom I think there's degrees to
it like okay you wear a little mascara
you wear a little eyeliner whatever but
like I think when guys most guys
definitely will start being like Oh it's
a bit much when it's like caked on yeah
full face Foundation etc etc so I
actually think that the woman should do
whatever makes them feel confident
I think it's it's nice as a man to
support your woman and make her know
that she's beautiful and that you find
her beautiful no matter what but
ultimately if it makes her feel more
confident then that's very empowering
and she should do it totally because how
much of us don't want how many of us
don't want to feel more confident
exactly
loser
um me personally I've like up oh hold on
and Martin super chatted fifty dollars
I'm six feet one inch so I'm just
arguing for the short Kings out there
ladies make up extensions eyelashes lip
fillers implants barrels high heels
that's all changing appearance EA
dishonest a beard is the natural state
of a man's face makeup is not
thank you Martin for the assist yo I
love always like yo I'm thank you for
helping me bro I was dying out here hey
I'm super tall just so you guys know I'm
super tall up front I'm just saying this
for the short dudes out there
the insecurity is oozing off these guys
appreciate you man you guys have a
response oh hold on dang they donated 50
and then they lie about height and how
rich they are but women lie about how
good they look in their way makeup gets
washed off and then they have to deal
with maintaining a beard messed up
trimming in may as well see okay so men
are the real victims they are going
there's the real struggle because yeah
we must shave
by the way let's ask him if he thinks
that women should have hair on their
legs yeah because I'm pretty sure you
got a lot more skin to shave down there
than we got on our face and I don't see
anyone advocating for that hey bro how
do you feel about Harry [__] hairy
butthole dude
I'm saying check me he's got no answer
to that all right you like a butthole
hairy or clean
[Laughter]
probably clean more that's right right
and who doesn't yeah I mean you're a
real Savage if you want to eat out a
hairy [__]
no some people like it it's a Savage
though yeah yeah
word
um did you guys have a response right
Gabe are you are you more into like a
hairy [__] or like a clean
clean one
maybe Harry's just so natural
let's not be presumptive here
he's just a is there like a caveman
you're like eating a hairy [__] bro
and you know when it's Harry Primal it's
got some dingles in there a little bit
probably a tissue yeah but you just like
it all anyway right Gabe yeah it's like
organic
do you like your [__] organic
and Mom I'm not gonna ask you okay
hair on my body yeah I didn't ask I
didn't want to know actually oh didn't
ask for any uh
didn't ask
okay thank you though
but if you get old though
you don't grow hair you stop growing
hair
yeah I don't have any hair on my arm my
forearms
I don't have hair on my leg I just I
don't know I just don't have any hair
that happens when you get older
something to look forward to I guess
laughs to uh
anything
that was said in the tts's
I don't think that women wearing makeup
is like they got a cricket sound like
really always wait that was that them I
was them dude oh you're gonna bring
these girls in under the pretense of
trying to bring them on and have a
religious conversation they destroy you
they leave you speechless and then the
moment it takes them to answer you hit
them with cricket sounds
uh
week [__] Bro shame on you saw
I hit a nugget because I hate him so
much
word
um did you guys have a response to uh
anything
that was said in the tts's
yeah that wasn't even like a full second
before they hit the cricket I wish I
could see his [__] ass hand touch it I
saw him eating like that was him he hit
it yeah I've seen him go up a little bit
but he's got the soundboard you can see
it yeah a little stream decoration bro
you gave him like
can you hit the clock I want to measure
how long between he finishes speaking
and he hits the cricket somebody
you got a timer ready damn
one moment
that's us
yeah we got crickets set up to show on
screen but you want me to just time yeah
yeah so all right
anything
that was said in the tts's
[Music]
I mean
I should have started it from right when
he finished talking and it would have
been less than less than a second yeah
yeah
barely a breath
I don't think that I literally went back
one frame yeah wearing makeup is like
generally always for men as a sound man
I should be ashamed of yourself yeah it
should be [__] ashamed to you jump in
the gun what an idiot that's such a
loser he does his own sound bites a
[__] [__] he's in a room by
himself doing his own cricket sound
bites to be a [__] shame to yourself
dude they should be a disaster
they said I'll just beat his ass that
would be awesome like the end of that
Tarantino movie where all the girls jump
that dude that's awesome girl power
what you're talking about is one of you
mentioned that and this this was just in
response to what one of you said you
said that men lie about their height and
I said well women lie about makeup
and but well they they lie about their
appearance through makeup and filters
but why don't we start first with
filters
um can you at least agree that using
these you've seen my man a Nook bro men
don't use filters
yeah I mean that's just ignorant at this
point everybody use filter yeah filters
are ubiquitous
you don't use the soft filter on tick
tock
do you use any filters Eddie yeah
but not recently but I had before my
first couple of years you know just to
test them out see where you go just fun
but you you one of the few people that
has such beautiful skin that you
actually wouldn't even need a film yeah
I don't really use it now yeah
God what's your skincare routine just
wash my face every night and in the
morning before I go somewhere and then
just put moisturizer on and then blessed
blessed all about that moisturizer you
lucky man yeah filters on a dating app
is disingenuous because I do you can say
what you will about makeup because you
can wear makeup in real life however
filters Photoshop that facetune that
does not exist yeah in real life can we
agree with that at least sure and I
definitely see a lot of girls use
filters on dating apps I do see that too
yeah yeah and some guys do it too
honestly be careful of the guys that use
face filters because them motherfucker's
crazy because they're so late dudes ah
this guy's the best I kind of want to
look at more whatever clips
that's how I describe them too I got
something for you whatever whatever go
ahead Amy what you got for me I sent in
Discord
I think
this is a fit bro who are you right now
this is him
why what is he doing with his life
you think there's a filter on it
it's not a real mustache
does this guy have a filter
that one yes yeah he does
that's a Nook yeah he's a famous singer
[Music]
all right enough ladies and gentlemen
let's see I wanna I want more of this
Andrew Tate triggers purple hair
feminists are you [__] kidding me is
that a real title from four months ago
you know what's so attractive about oh
he had
oh
I cannot believe how many people like
this there are there a lot of these
dudes talk about fertility and yeah
looks and stuff boring literally boring
that dude's in jail fix your [__]
audio you idiots it's like that video
was just so like like what
fix that [__] whatever
let's see do not date women who party
Patrice O'Neill triggers only fan girls
uh well whatever
that's what his is whatever douche
[Music]
yeah so
this has been an interesting episode
you did a bleeding hike losing Edge yeah
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
I think it worked it worked really good
and you you uh your fans really like to
see the see you go out and about in the
real world sometimes too and so you
showed him a little bit beside you that
you haven't seen before that's very true
I don't think they've seen me order
McDonald's before last it's always
brought into you and then you know
they'll you'll say hey thanks for
bringing it and but yet this way you we
saw you go out there and I was we were
the anticipation of what is he doing
where is he where in the world is he and
what did he leave the studio or
something going on right so there's not
many show hosts who would be bold and
Adventure enough to leave their Studio
that's right in the hands of
frankly this is our first time meeting a
person a stranger I appreciate but I
trust I'm honored thank you so much and
it's been a pleasure and I love to be
seeing you in person
yeah
you heard about Dilbert
yeah I heard about that he's uh I can't
believe that after all those years of
him doing the comic strip he could act
like a racist dude you really do know so
much you are actually up today oh where
do you get your news from usually just
you know reading the paper or you know
seeing people that read the comics or
you know books or you know like just uh
watching it on TV or you know on the
internet but you're up to date I like
him I believe he's also I know now gone
Rogue the Dilbert guy yeah this is the
dude who wrote Dilbert who's been like a
long time he's a trumpy guy a Maga dude
and um
he
has already kind of been on the outs for
being just like a total weirdo but he
went full mask off here uh five days ago
real coffee with Scott Adams
more like a real racist
yeah I can't believe that he would go
off like so here he is Scott Adams of
Dilbert maybe Trump paid him to say all
those you think so could be he had a
trump back in like
presidency
but like this dude he did this I mean
bro this is you this is you wow
you know Dilbert did you ever like
Dilbert mom that was of your time
no not really yeah Dilbert sucks
yeah
I like the little dog
you're like what the little dog that's
in it Dilbert dog the Dilbert dog dog
bird dog bird is his name I just think
he's cute
okay well you're supporting white
supremacy dance so watch it oh he is
cute this dog rules that's what I'm
saying yeah Heroes I like him it's a
cute design the dog's white oh so true
today
they said uh do you agree or disagree
with the statement uh it's okay to be
white
that was an actual question right is it
done Rasmussen asked you know white and
black voters
and and probably others uh do you
disagree or agree with a statement it's
okay to be white
26 of blacks said uh no
it's not okay to be white
21 weren't sure
Adam together that is 47 of black
respondents
were not willing to say it's okay to be
white
that that actually that's like a real
poll
this just happened
question do you have any idea
would would you have imagined that that
could have happened
so I realized um as you know I've been
identifying as black for a while years
now
because I like you know I like to be on
the winning team
I wish I was black man they just can't
stop winning yeah
to help and I always thought well if you
helped the black community
that's sort of the biggest lever you
know you could you can find the the
biggest benefit so I thought well that's
the hardest thing and the biggest
benefit I hope people to benefit myself
but he's saying that you know helping
the black community is that's that's the
best way to help yourself so that's why
I did it right now it's really is really
he's really laying the foundations of a
strong argument here
a lot of my life resources in helping
black Americans so much so that I
started identifying as black
to just be on the team I was helping
but it turns out that nearly half of
that team doesn't think
I'm okay to be white
which is of course why I identified as
black because I could be on the winning
team for a while
but I have to say this is the first
political poll that ever changed my
activities
I don't know that that's ever happened
before you know normally you see a poll
you just look at it you go ah whatever
yeah oh this is interesting what other
people think
but as of today I'm going to re-identify
as white
group I've accidentally joined a hate
group
so if if you know nearly half of All
Blacks uh are not okay with white people
according to this poll not according to
me
according to this poll
uh that's a hate noob
that's a hate group and I don't want to
have anything to do with them
I don't have anything to do with black
people what do you think because being
black at part of a hate cold no
no
good answer
you nailed that
thank you
so
I have a whole hamburger in my mouth at
this moment
there was another actress that said she
was you know not white or black she was
just Universal and that was you know she
was uh recently uh she was from The
Cosby Show one of the Cosby's bands uh
the little girl from The Cosby uh that
grew up to have her own sitcom a couple
of Disney sitcoms but she on The View
said she doesn't believe that she's
black or white she was just Universal
and it shouldn't be that was her belief
system Raven Raven Simone yeah she said
that she was uh so he's just sort of
keying into that but later on years
later it was only like four or five
years ago that Raven Simone said on The
View that she felt like she was you know
not identified as black and she always
said all the time that she doesn't have
to be saying that she's black all the
time and it got a lot of controversy on
the face I can see why sure but here's
the pull he's referring to I just think
it's so funny because
it was conducted by Rasmussen I don't
know if they're credible I know that
they're like very right right did you
not see the things I was sending this
morning but like what's their like pull
credibility rating because I know
there's websites that rate
how biased they are uh they're they're
known to have a right leaning bias but
moreover they also just uh pretty
explicitly endorsed uh
for example during uh the lead up to
January 6th they were from their their
official account tweeting that Mike
Pence should overturn the election and
stuff well that's uh biased that gives
you an idea of where where they're at
you heard that okay so so here here's
why this poll is so weird first of all
asking if it's okay to be white
is such a conf it's a nonsensical
question it's like asking you know is it
okay to have brown hair right well it's
a natural attribute
what does it mean
their starting point is the
Anti-Defamation League has labeled it's
okay to be white as hate speech
and so that's where I think
if if there were black people voting for
this and they said no it's not okay I
think you could easily misinterpret this
question as something to do with like
proud and white more leaning towards the
kind of white supremacy angle of like
it's okay you know yeah because you you
hear that's like a slogan you hear
amongst
uh these kind of PR proud to be white
people it's okay to be white and so
I find the whole
way that this was conducted to be
extremely misleading dishonest and the
question itself was just total nonsense
so
it's it's pretty incredible though but
they they got what they wanted and
apparently now Dilbert has come out he
is wants nothing to do with black people
Gilbert yeah
Gilbert was uh but not maybe not the
character which is the comic where
Dilbert asked to be moved away from his
black neighbor in his office was that in
there I have a just been informed of
something really wild by our mod Mega
awesome nerd that apparently there were
no black characters in Dilbert comic at
all for like 33 years well there you go
so until last year and this is the first
introduction wait he still makes Dilbert
comics yeah yeah that's the thing and
now he's getting dropped all over the
place
man so here zoom in on that so here is
his first ever black character Dilbert
management asked me to add some
diversity to the engineering team Meet
Dave I identify as white you're ruining
everything Dave
that's a proper use of the Crickets and
I mean I mean come on Dilbert come on
man
disgraceful it's disgraceful
right thank you Mom and Gabe uh your
thoughts
baby's sleeping
yeah yeah go ahead Gabe what are your
thoughts on uh Dilbert
I guess it's it's not good right right
right nailed it
all right you nailed it Gabe
you're on your [__] dude
[__] yeah
this is pretty Cutting Edge content
right here guys
yeah maybe Dilbert thought that you know
he's going to be canceled anyway in a
few years because uh probably he's seen
some of the older comic strips being
taken off of National syndication right
so he's just figuring well I better
cater to that audience because then I'll
be able to have Dilbert in like you know
with some of the Breitbart yeah so true
wow that's a good point and that's my
new Niche you know because of the fact
that uh I know they're going to cancel
my strip anyway in a few months or weeks
or a year interesting plays so true that
could be why he's playing this card and
he's doing the same thing that Roseanne
did when she lost her sitcom right when
Roseanne said that you know about that
congresswoman and then they killed her
character off on her own sitcom right
now there she is
my favorite
I thought the best one
best wife that's Roseanne and then she
said Trump was the first female
president afterwards because she wishes
she had said that instead of what she
said about Mary jury Barrett or you know
whatever
hey
you think um you follow Jake Paul versus
Tommy Fury yeah dude you're on your ship
oh wow I love you I love you back you're
right on everything what are your
thoughts on the fight he lost right yeah
he really shouldn't have lost you know
he's probably going to be
uh regretting that you know of his whole
life now were you with Team Jake Paul
yeah you were and why is that
well because you know he he happened to
have no I'm just kidding I don't know
anything about Jake Paul never heard of
it wow
you broke him man you almost had me
though I wouldn't be surprised you know
everything yeah yeah so Tommy Fury beat
Jake Paul
he's a giant loser as I always suspected
right Gabe
yep thank you
well [__] uh
didn't think I'd ever have to make one
of these videos but [__] happens I guess
this is still the best job in the world
thank you all for support this was an
amazing event and I'll be back no
worries cuz uh interestingly the first
actual like active boxer he's fought
beat him
just saying
you know there was uh where's this clip
oh yeah here's a here's a little
compilation of Jake before and after the
fight which I appreciate
so this was the first professional fight
or were they all professional it's just
the other people they were professional
but this was the first person who was
like an active boxer right yeah they
were all like well retired and not
boxers right so do those count for his
Like official record yeah yes they do
they were officials bogus I feel like
he's zero or zero and one
the first real fight you can no you
could do like me and Honda were gonna do
a professional fight at first okay but
then I found out the gloves were like a
lot lighter I'm like [__] that I'm not
trying to get brain damage I didn't know
what I was getting into okay are you
doing all right I am not only Ian is I
believe Ian and wasabi Ian's gonna kill
him
so technically Ian still doesn't have
any losses professionally so
right oh he's undefeated he's undefeated
zero and zero so here's Jake before and
after let's take a look 100 are we
getting all of the Jake Paul that you
can bring tonight no injuries no
problems we're coming in 100 yes sir
you're getting Jake Joseph Paul the name
legendary let's get it baby it's time
what was he Nelson Nelson from this
okay he's uh the problem child that's
the that's his problem child sound he
makes perfect branding so it is Nelson
like he's kind of leaning like I'm I'm
the obnoxious kid from The Simpsons
that's embarrassing for sure
training and strategy was successful
tonight honestly I felt flat I got sick
really bad twice in this Camp injured my
arm why'd they start doing them yeah
yeah he sounds like you Ethan yeah tired
I got kids I don't have a babysitter
like me when I don't want to go out
dude he got mangled his face looks
messed up 100 are we getting all the
Jake Paul you can bring tonight no
injuries I don't get it he says he's
getting 100 but then when he loses he
says I've been sick I hurt my arm I
didn't have a babysitter it's like he's
full of excuses yeah what a loser right
loser
right on right on right on
look at this dark ass [__] white
supremacist this is the guy who did the
poll last faith in polling but let me
explain our role at Rasmussen reports
and prove to you right now more than
ever you need us to exist you need to
tell you what America really thinks and
I can tell you that increasing the Race
Rewards are coming everybody it's Mark
Mitchell from Rasputin get ready the the
rich Wars are coming you need me to tell
us let me reaffirm your paranoid
worldview
think of American public opinion does
not match what you're being told in the
news at schools or colleges by
corporations and by Republic officials
follow the links to our two biggest hold
on uh I'm gonna pause you there but this
is important
were you were you working on Jake Paul
going back to the Senior Citizen Center
to find his next opponent
that's right that's right that's what
I'm saying
biggest polls of the year which I'll put
in the YouTube description for an
example about how we changed the
narrative by proving covid vaccinated
Americans are suffering from major side
effects and how nearly half the country
is concerned the vaccines are causing a
significant number of unexplained deaths
what
How likely is it they're not scientists
these are dumb [__] people yeah what
do they know I mean how many times
you've been vaccinated right here yeah
how many times oh at least 25 times mom
he's been vaccinated side effects from
that he's had 25 covet vaccinations
why why 25 well you know I had to be vax
boosted boosted again but mostly just so
that uh you know I thought uh if I could
do it so that I'd never get covet and
also I just thought maybe it'll help you
know and I wanted to see uh what you
know pretty much that I wouldn't get it
you know over 19 and it was fun and you
have him yeah
well I mean I've had all my boosters and
all my shots but it didn't amount to 25
times
um you know I mean if you're gonna get
covered you're gonna get it but you
won't get deathly ill which is under the
whole life how many times have you been
vaccinated mom
um let's see one two three I think
there's three or four vaccinations
how much do you think you need how much
do you think she needs to be fully
covered she's good you're pretty good
you're just maybe I've gotten everything
that was required and they won't let you
take it you know oh they will if you if
you peel off the stickers oh no yeah
and then maybe uh get tell them you've
never had it before yeah you just lie to
them well that way you know at least
you'd be really feeling uh like you were
totally uh taken care of
because you never know they could have
diluted it the first time ever could
have given you a half a dose or it
didn't go in right that's true that's
true
you're covering your base yeah
so Mom you can go lie to them and get
more
okay
you know I
well
that's really important well health
before everything yeah
Gabe how many times you've been
vaccinated
three times
I had Clover twice and that hasn't
worked well for you yeah you got to pump
those three days
have you considered getting more
vaccinations Gabe
I'm dead right now he's good
he's sleepy he's good
okay I'm glad everyone's good though why
did he do it because we are real public
opinion journalists who don't take
checks from either party how about you
just give me the results and stuff don't
do this high horse thing you [__]
dork
why do we do it we're super important
we're awesome and super important anyway
black people are hate uh send brace Wars
are coming
who aren't beholden to a massive
Corporation and who have never once even
been sent a single talking point
part of doing what we do is asking the
questions others won't like the vaccine
questions but here's such a dork [__]
loser literally melt the brain of a
mainstream journalist if they tried to
put these numbers to Ink why because it
conclusively undermines the current
racial Orthodox it occur it undermines
what we all already knew black people
hate us oh
mm-hmm
get your rifles boy
hey Rasputin said the black people
coming for us now get you get your
rifles ready boys I knew it
mm-hmm not Rasputin
hey that Mark Mitchell told me get my
rifle ready
come on now everybody
let's hole up in the church
just start taking shots Mark Mitchell
said so
um
I knew it
I knew it my neighbor
you black I knew he eyeballing me weird
um
one time I was walking by he's outside
washing his car and he said hi to me but
it wasn't right the way he said it I
could read between the lines yes sir
Mark Mitchell said so
in it
no supporting music exactly I mean do I
got a bag
really oh dude you guys turned on me
today all right now as a caveat I have
absolutely no idea how YouTube is going
to take this one but all we did was ask
very simple questions
on YouTube no it's so [__] racist
controversial oh yeah YouTube's not good
anymore right he says so [__]
what an idiot [__] dummy
stupid ass [__] dumbass dork
what Americans told us nothing more do
you agree or disagree with this
statement it's okay to be white
mind-blowingly or perhaps not the vast
majority of American advice
which is it is it mind-blowing or not
mind-blowingly or or totally expected
what is it which one is it so were they
explicitly prompted to do this poll
because of the ADL thing yes it was in
it was in the context right I don't know
how they got these votes but on their
tweet they did it in context of ADL
saying it's okay to be white as a hate
term right so I mean there was like an
active like coordinated trolling
campaign that originated from 4chan to
spread that around which is explicitly
what the 80 I pulled it up their website
they're explicitly referring to that and
so they basically
heard that a bunch of white supremacists
went out of their way to make this
phrase like their slogan and then ask
people if they were okay with it and
then when they said no
blame them for being upset because the
question is this is no sense yeah like
it's okay to be white I disagree it's
like what are you disagreeing with yeah
it doesn't make any sense
my guess is that I mean it's just like
the is like the phrase all lives matter
it's like on its face yeah that isn't
like a controversial thing and it's like
how could you disagree with that but
obviously if you're aware of the context
that that's like always being said in
reply 100 to Black lives matter as a way
of kind of competing with it or whatever
then suddenly it has a whole different
angle and by the way there's only a
thousand people that that participated
in this right I'm not sure yet
that's statistically is significant
right people are saying it's a bad poll
and you know what for once
I got to agree it's a bad hole it's an
actual bad point this is a real bad pull
take take part uh Dan this is a real bad
pull maybe your polls weren't so bad
after that's what I'm saying that's what
I've been trying to say here
a 58 strongly agree only 12 percent
that's like that's like let's see do you
think it's okay to be black I mean go
ahead go ask that question let's see
what the results are
do you think it's okay to be a a ham
sandwich
we don't talk about that yeah sorry we
don't talk about I have sandwiches yeah
do you think that would be insulting to
call someone a ham sandwich what are
your thoughts on that yes yes it would
be yeah okay thank you Eddie
what is it you would what is it you
think they're trying to say if they
called someone a ham sandwich
oh that they're uh you know lower grade
lower human you know lower human degrade
them just like terrible ugly not fat
giving them bullying not fat yeah not
not fat
you guys hear that I did hear that
six percent of those strongly now 17 of
Americans are not sure and that's a
pretty big number for a question like
this seventy percent were confused by
this nonsensical question
should be a simple question to answer to
me that is the standout number people
berated or guilted so much that they
won't anonymously submit a response to
an ivr caller because they know it's
probably a gotcha it's it's like because
people aren't [__] stupid and just
like the all lives matter thing you know
like they even if they hadn't directly
heard of this they're like if you're
asking me this it's
probably because somebody I don't like
is saying it kind of thing 100 percent
proud boys is actually uh trending
what's going on there speaking of which
proud boys
if you don't believe the gun industry is
now full on support domestic terrorists
I give you the official Instagram post
for Smith and Wesson
how's this proud boy related
oh is this a shirt
proud what they posted a proud boy
that's crazy Smith and Wesson did yes
oh that's [__] nuts
all right we've been going for a long
time we have I'd love for you to come
back would you do that anytime at any
place yeah you have a great time and
I'll be here thanks man thank you so
much for having me and I loved it I
loved it I loved having you here and
thank you and so I want to say um
shirtless Eddie is on Tick Tock yes
Eddie
lavesi are you on a cameo or anything no
not yet maybe you're considered I've
been saying I should be in there yeah
I'll send the people then okay yeah
thank you so much I'm gonna wrap it up
too so we can talk a little bit before
you go but thank you to Gabe Gabe who's
a who's a legend thank you for joining
us today Gabe
Gabriel we missed you last Friday Gabe
I know
and this is going on yeah you see you're
pretty busy okay yeah
you go on another date Gabe you get any
any progress there
um we'll see if I get any um notices
okay okay we'll talk on Friday yeah
yeah baby
mom thank you so much Donna Klein on
Cameo right Mom yes that's right we love
it
this has been a weird and interesting
video uh episode
you know Eddie
I did this because I was so impressed
with your the thing about going to
McDonald's I hope you're not offended
because I thought it was so impressive
what you were able to do
and the how you had so many stories just
incredible came out of me yeah and so
all of a sudden
I thought it'd be you know
I was doing a little stick right but
yeah it was a good time thank you so
much it was perfectly fine thank you
we love you today all right guys have a
good uh evening everybody watching at
home tomorrow is see you next Tuesday
for our lovely members and also I'll be
seeing you all next Tuesday this is a
weird weird one for you guys but hey
that's what it is
can everybody say capiche on three Gaben
and my mom ready one two three
and you guys too no one two three ready
one two three
and that's what it is that's what it is
what it is see you guys uh members
tomorrow and everyone else on Wednesday
love you see you Sunday okay love you
too Mom
[Music]
back
foreign